MORNING FOLKS IN RESPONSE TO
THE COPA NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
WOULD NEEDED NUMBER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING ALSO A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TODAY WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY- FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEES
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TW.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO
THREE FOUR EIGHT ZERO TWO FOUR
THAT'S TWO THREE FOUR EIGHT
ZERO TWO FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT TO BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATE YOUR CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE ON YOU DID AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
WILL BE ALLOWING FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ON
EACH BILL TO HEAR FROM AS MANY
PEOPLE AS TIME PERMITS WE ASK
YOU TO SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY IN TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
A HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HERE IN PROCESS
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO TITANS. MANNER
DISCUSSED. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE NOW
HAVE FOURTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA AND EIGHT OF THOSE BILLS
ARE ON PROPOSED CONSENT- THAT'S
THE CONSENT CALENDAR LOOKS AS
FOLLOWS THAT FILE ITEM ONE AB
SIXTY THREE FILE ITEM FIVE AB
THREE FIFTEEN. FILE ITEM SIX
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY ONE FILE
ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
NINE. FILE ITEM TEN. AB SEVEN
EIGHTY ONE. FILE ITEM ELEVEN.
AB EIGHT OH FOUR. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN NINETY.
AND FILE ITEM. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY. BEFORE YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S
LET'S ESTABLISH WELL. MEDIA
FORM WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- SO WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM ONCE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT MEMBERS BUT FOR
RIGHT NOW WILL WILL CONVENE AS
A SUB COMMITTEE- AND WE LET'S
START WITH THIS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE MISTER WARD
HERE- OKAY LET'S LET'S THEN
SWITCH OVER TO MISTER WARD- AS
A MEMBER YOU WANT TO COME UP
AND PRESENT I THINK YOU'VE GOT
TO MEASURES BEFORE US TODAY.
MISTER CHAIR IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
LIKE WHAT WE WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO TO THREE ITEM NUMBER THREE-
MISTER CARE MEMBERS AB TWO TO
THREE MAKES IT UNLAWFUL TO TAKE
DUDLEY A FROM ITS NATURAL
HABITAT. ON LAND OWNED BY THE
STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR ON
PROPERTY THAT THE TOP ONE HOME.
AND ESTABLISHES MINIMUM
EFFECTIVE PENALTIES W. AS A
GENUS OF SUCCULENTS INCLUDE
FORTY SEVEN SPECIES TWENTY SIX
WHICH CAN BE FOUND IN NEED OF
HABITATS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
RECENTLY THE GENUS BECOME
INCREDIBLY POPULAR AND SOME
OTHER COUNTRIES A SINGLE PLANT
TYPICALLY SELL FOR FIFTY TO
EIGHTY DOLLARS OR UP TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A LARGER
AND MORE MATURE DUDLEYA PLANTS.
AS A RESULT POACHERS HAVE BEEN
HARVESTING W. BY THE THOUSANDS
TARGETING LARGER MORE MATURE
PLANTS ALONG CALIFORNIA'S COAST
AND THEN SHIPPING AND SELLING
THEM ELSEWHERE. WHAT THE COURTS
HAVE BEEN CREATED IN PENALIZING
POACHERS THE FINE AMOUNTS THAT
CAN BE LEVY ARE MINUSCULE WHEN
COMPAREDTO THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
POACHERS CAN MAKE SELLING THE
PLANTS ON THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET. THE PENALTIES TO
ALISTAIR AB TWO TO THREE OR
ANALOGOUS WITH RECENTLY CATION
TO ADDRESS IVORY AND SHARK FIN
POACHING. LIKE SUPPOSEDLY
MAKING UNLAWFUL APPROACH BADLY-
AND ESTABLISHING STRONGER
PENALTIES FOR VIOLATIONS AB TWO
TO THREE WILL HELP TO DETERMINE
W. APPROACHING AND PROMOTE
EFFECTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT. ON
THE PHONE WE HAVE NICK JENSEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AND STEPHEN
MCCABE WITH UC. SANTA CRUZ TO
TESTIFY TO THIS BILL. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MEMORY MEMBER- WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES TESTIFYING ON THE
LINE. OPERATOR WE HAVE NICK
JENSEN STEVE MCCABE. OR CALL
THE FIRST WITNESS. GERMAN YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN HI MY NAME IS
STEPHEN MCCABE ON THE EMERITUS
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH FOR THE UC
SANTA CRUZ ARBORETUM. I'VE BEEN
STUDYING DEADLY SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE YEAH CONSIDER THE
EXPERT ON THAT GROUP. ALTHOUGH
COLLEAGUES RELATED COACHING
INCIDENTS IN PAST DECADES AND
I'VE NOTED OCCASIONAL PLACES
WERE THAT THEY WERE MISSING
FROM THE WILD. THE RECENT
DECADE HAS SEEN A PHENOMENAL
INCREASE IN POACHING THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPORTS. HAS
AMOUNTED TO TONS OF THE SMALL
PLANTS BEING POACHED IN THE
SIGNAL PATH. BONTA SUCH AS SOME
AND NEED TO BE ON THE INSIDE
AND MITES THE PM DEADLY THE HOT.
OWLS AND OTHER BIRDS THAT FEED
ON THOSE WILL SUFFER IF
POACHING CONTINUES UNABATED.
AFTER HEARING OF POACHING OF
THE NEWLY NAMES DEADLY AT
NINETEEN NINETY IRATE. FRANCE
FIRST MONTHLY QUITE COLLECTED
GARDEN SHEET IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE YEARS OLD PLANTS AT A LOW
PRICE AND IT SEEMS THAT BROUGHT
DOWN THE PRICE FOR THAT SPECIES
CALIFORNIA. I HAD HOPED MY WORK
WAS DONE BUT ABOUT FOUR YEARS
AGO I RIDICULOUS MUCH TOO MUCH
IT WAS AGAIN THE TARGET OF.
THESE THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN TO
THE WORLD. PER SEVERAL AND
OWNING OBSCURE DUDLEY HAS
BECOME THE SAME WORLD BY. THIS
SPECIES HAS NOT BEEN NAMED I
HAVE OBSERVED THAT EXIST. HAS
ALMOST NO PROTECTION. I AM IN
THE PROCESS OF NAMING A NEW
SPECIES THAT ARE SO RARE. THAT
THEY WERE NOT WELL KNOWN UNTIL
RECENTLY. CONTROVERSIAL
MEDIAPOST EMAIL QUESTIONS I
RECEIVED. THEIR HINTS THAT THE
POACHERS ARE MOVING ON TO A
RARE SPECIES. INCLUDING AN
UNNAMED THAT COULD QUICKLY GO
EXTINCT. I RECOMMEND PASSAGE OF.
EIGHTY TWO TO THREE TO PROTECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT YOU SO
MUCH- NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
NICK JENSEN AND I AM THE
CONSERVATION PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY BY ORGANIZATION AS A
SPONSOR FOR A B. TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER OUR SINCEREST THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORK FOR KERRY
BUT STILL. MISS MCCABE JUST
HIGHLIGHTED THE PROBLEM OF
DEADLY APPROACHING IS NOT GOING
AWAY LAWSUIT ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS ESTIMATETHAT
THOUSANDS OF THAT THE A PLAN TO
BERMAN AND REMOVED FROM
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL AREAS.
HERE'S OUR STATE IS FORTUNATE
TO BE HOME TO MORE THAN FIVE
THOUSAND SPECIES OF PLANTS MANY
OF WHICH. ARE FOUND NOWHERE
ELSE ON EARTH. IT IN THE SPEECH
HE ICLUDING NUMEROUS. ARE
EXTREME RARE. AS A RESULT. OF
EIGHTEEN. A SERIOUS
CONSERVATION THREAT SOME
SPECIES OF DUDLEYA. AB TWO
TWENTY THREE GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
TARGET ILLEGAL POACHING
OPERATION. THEY CLARIFIED THAT
REMOVING DEADLY FROM LAND
CALIFORNIA IS ILLEGAL WITHOUT
LANDOWNER PERMISSION OR A
PERMIT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE. IT ESTABLISHES
APPROPRIATE PENALTIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF
HARVESTING DUDLEY A LEGALLY.
THIS BILL THE NECESSARY STEPS
TO FOR TO DETER FUTURE COACHING
OPERATIONS. TRANSCATHETER
MARKLE BIODIVERSITY FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWENTY
THREE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ANYONE MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THANK YOU
MISTER CHEN AND- MY PA I
INADVERTENTLY FAIL YOU GUYS
ACTUALLY TO THE GUY. THAT BUT I
IN IT DIDN'T RIDLEY FAILED TO
NOTE YOU OF THEM. GOING FORTY
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED THREE
MINUTES TOTAL FOR THE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THANKS FOR
STAYING WITHIN THOSE
CONSTRAINTS BUT ALL OTHER
WITNESSES. WISHING TO TESTIFY
GOING FORWARD MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO JUST NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION WE'RE
IN IT AGAIN AS I SAID AT THE
OUTSET LIMIT TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
PER SIDE SO- WE CAN NOW. MOVE
TO ANY WITNESSES PRESENT. IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. OKAY NO
WITNESSES PRESENT- LET'S BEGIN-
ANYWAY THIS IS A FORTY TWO
THREE OR GALLERY. NO ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
OR LET'S CHECK OUR CONFERENCE
LINE OPERATOR. THANK YOU AND IN
ORDER TO REGISTER- REGISTER
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME IN EIGHTEEN T.
SPECIALIST WILL PROVIDE YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AND NEAR LINE
NUMBER WILL BE CALLED WHEN WE
OPEN YOUR LINE UP. WE WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE. NUMBER OF
FORTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO
THREE THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR- KIM
DELFINO REPRESENTING DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT OF AB T.
TWENTY THREE. WE HAVE ONE MORE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
BLIND TWENTY TWO. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. HELLO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU
THIS IS AN OLD SCHOOL TO THE
COASTAL ST PETER NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL AND WE JUST PASSED A
MOTION OF SUPPORT FOR A B. TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND ARE GOING TO
BE SENDING THAT OFF TO THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES- URGING THE CITY
COUNCIL TO ALSO SUPPORT EIGHTY
TWO TWENTY THREE I'M NOT SURE
BECAUSE ON A PARKS COMMITTEE
AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT. WE
HAVE NO FOR THE LINES INTO IT
THIS TIME. OKAY WE WILL MOVE
FROM SUPPORT NOW IT'S PERCENT
PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHICH IS
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN A REMOTE HEARING ROOMS.
OPERATOR ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TESTIFIED PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND CALL THEM
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
TO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE ARE KNOWING QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY SENIOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. COMMENTS YES.
ESPECIALLY JERRY JONES THE
MEASURE THANKS AS A MEMBER
REWARDED AS WE WERE GOING
THROUGH YOUR- WITNESSES I JUST
GOOGLE THIS IN A REAL QUICK
AND- THERE'S SOME PRETTY
AMAZING PICTURES FROM
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE ON THEIR INTERCEPTION
OF YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
POACHERS. I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT IT'S YOUR BILL
JUST MAKES ILLEGAL APPROACH IT
DOESN'T TELL YOU LEGAL TO HAVE
IT OR GROW IT OR POSSESS IT IF
IT'S REQUIRED LEGALLY IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT ACTUALLY
GROW QUITE WELL IN NURSERIES UP
BUT THE POACHERS DON'T WANT TO
WAIT SEVERAL YEARS FOR THE
PLANTS TO MATURE. RIGHT I THINK
I HAVE SOME I WANT TO START
FINDING A WAY TO MULTIPLY IT AT
HOME SO. I CAN DO IT LEGALLY SO
I SUPPORT THE BILL AND MAKE
MOTION FOR APPROVAL BECAUSE
ANNA K. THAT'S A MOTION SENATOR
HUESO AND GIVE A COMMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THAT- A SPECIES
OF DEADLY A THAT IS FERMENTED
IN USE FOR ALCOHOL THAT'S
CALLED THE DEADLY OF MORE. I'M
NOT I'M NOT BUT- IF IT'S ONE OF
THE FORTY SEVEN THAT IT'S
SOMETHING ON TO GET BETTER
EDUCATED MAKE A DRINK CALLED
OUR TO ANYWAY THE STUDY. ANYWAY
I JUST. MOVE THE BILL. FREDDIE
THE- MOST. AND THE FACT. THAT
IT AM CLASS I TOOK THE IS NEVER.
FROM CENTER. TO HOSTED A- AND-
THE MOTION IN A COMMENT. OTHER
COMMENTS OR- EXTRA MOTIONS-
BOOKS MIGHT HAVE ONE QUESTION
IS THAT IS THAT WHAT IS BEING
POACHED FOR. NO SENATOR- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
A AN EXTREME AMOUNT OF POACHING
THAT IS GOING ON FOR OVERSEAS
IS FOR ME TO GET IT. IT FOR-
RESIDENTIAL USE TO BEAUTIFY ONE
SPACE AND INDEED IT DID THEY
DON'T THEY DON'T GROW IN YOUR
AREAS AS MUCH MA'AM. OUR
SIGNATURE LIKE WEEDS ALMOST.
WELL I WOULD SUPPOSE THAT IT IS
THE CONDITIONS COULD BE CREATED
FOR THEM TO BE GROWN ELSEWHERE
BUT AGAIN- WE'RE FINDING THAT
THE TRADE MARKET IS INTERESTED
AND PROCURING YOU KNOW SPECIES
THAT HAVE BEEN GROWING FOR FIVE
TEN UP TO A HUNDRED YEARS. IN
OUR NATIVE HABITAT. THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENTS
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
MEMBERS. MISTER CHIEF CONSOLE
WOULD YOU CALL THE- THE ROLE
HERE. STERN YEAR TURN HERE
JONES I'M HERE JONES HERE ALLEN.
ALLEN HERE EGGMAN YOUR EGGMAN
HERE GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO HERE
HUESO HERE LAYERED- LAYERED
HERE LONG. WE HAVE A CORE OKAY
WE HAVE A CORPSMAN OUR STATUS
AS A FULL COMMITTEE- APPRECIATE
THE- FRESHMAN THE I'M NOT SURE
TREATMENT FROM COMMITTEE WILL
REGAIN SOME ORDER AND ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IT'S AN EXCELLENT
BILL AND- CRITICAL PROTECTION
FOR MANY ENDANGERED AND- YOU
KNOW REAR FOR SPECIES AND
PUTTING DOWN THIS BLACK MARKET
I THINK THE MOTION WILL BE TO
REFER. TO PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AS WELL YET ONE MORE
STOP PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE'S COMMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS- ASK YOU TO
SAVE THE DUDS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. GOOD
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION HERE
ON A. B. TWO TO THREE IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY STERN. STERN ALL RIGHT
JONES JONES HI ALAN. ACCELERATE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROWS.
HERTZBERG HUESO HI HUESO
ALRIGHT LAYERED HI LITTERED ALL
RIGHT LIMóN. OKAY WE'LL LEAVE
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU SO
MANY MEMBER- YOU ONE MORE ITEM
BEFORE IT'S HERE THANK YOU YES
I HAVE A NUMBER FOR AB FIVE
HUNDRED. PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LET ME
START BY ACCEPTING THE CHAIR
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK KATHIR MORE. FOR ALL
HER HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. WE
KNOW CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE A SEVERE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS WITH THE
DEFICIENCY OF THREE MILLION
HOMES AND GROWING. THE ISSUE
WAS EXACERBATED IN RESIDENTIAL
AREAS OF THE COASTAL ZONE WHERE
DEVELOPMENTS FACE VARIOUS
CHALLENGES. EIGHTY USES
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. CAN PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS TO HELP THE CURRENT
HOUSING CRISIS FOR MIDDLE AND
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS YET.
UNDER UTILIZED IN THE COASTAL
ZONE IN PART DUE TO THE TIME
INTENSIVE NATURE OF THE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT PROCESS. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS IN RECENT
YEARS. PASS LAWS TO STREAMLINE
THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESSES FOR
EIGHTY YEARS SUPPORT OF A
HOUSING AND- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. HOWEVER WHILE THOSE
HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES THEY
DID NOT EXTEND TO CDP'S WHICH
ARE AS YOU KNOW ESTATE PROCESS.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT. THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
HAS TAKEN STEPS TO CLARIFY THE
REGULATORY PROCESS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADOPT. HOWEVER
IT IS NOT EXPRESSLY WITHIN THE
COMMISSION SCOPE. TO PROMOTE
SOLUTIONS. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE. WITH OPPOSITION FROM THE
COMMISSION THE LEGISLATURE
AMENDED THE COASTAL ACT AND
REMOVED LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING POLICIES FOR MISTER
STICTION. AB FIVE HUNDRED WOULD
REINSTATE THE COASTAL ACT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICIES.
THAT WERE REPEALED FORTY YEARS
AGO TO GIVE THE COMMISSION THE
AUTHORITY. TO PROTECT EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND ENSURE
THAT NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
CONSISTENT WITH COASTAL ACT
POLICIES. THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
UPDATE AND STREAMLINE. THE
REGULATORY CDP PROCESS FOR
EIGHTY YEARS JUNIOR EIGHTY
YEARS. SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
1100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHIN
THE COASTAL ZONE. AND I'M
WORKING WITH THE COMMISSION TO
MAKE SURE THAT PROCESS IS
EXPEDITIOUS AND SIMPLE. THE
BILL RETAIN SUPPORT FOR
EVALUATION PROTECTIONS OF
SENSITIVE ENOUGH TO RESOURCES.
IN THE COASTAL ZONE WHILE
REMOVING BARRIERS FOR THESE
HOUSING TYPES. BY APPROVING AB
FIVE HUNDRED. COASTAL
COMMUNITIES WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
POSTAL COMMISSION AND PROVIDE
NEW HOUSING SOLUTIONS. AND TO
ENSURE THAT NOT JUST VISITORS
SERVING. ACCOMMODATIONS BUT
ALSO RESIDENTS SO. TO THE- IS
BETTER FOR YOU TO ALL. I'D LIKE
TO PRESENT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL WE HAVE ZERO CHRISTIE
THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FROM
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION. AND BILL PRINCE
LOOKING THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF PEOPLE ORGANIZED FOR
WESTSIDE RENEWAL. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LET'S TURN TO OUR FIRST
WITNESS- AGAIN EACH SIDE WE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES TOTAL
FOR THE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
AND THEN- GENERAL ME TO USE FOR
THE- FIFTEEN MINUTES ELSEWHERE
FOR SIDE SO- MODERATOR WOULD
YOU- PLEASE CALL THE FIRST
WITNESS. SO I JUST GO. ONE IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CARE NUMBERS I'M
SURE CHRISTY WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHICH IS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
HUNDRED. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE WELL AWARE OF
COMPLEX MANDATES TO PROTECT
CULTURAL RESOURCES LIKE
SENSITIVE HABITATS WETLANDS AND
PUBLIC ACCESS. BUT YOU MAY NOT
KNOW THAT WHEN THE COAST LACK
WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX IT ALSO INCLUDED A POLICY
TO PROTECT AND PROVIDE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WHICH WAS
CONSIDERED AT THE TIME A
COASTAL RESOURCE. FOR THE FIRST
FIVE YEARS OF THE PROGRAM THE
COMMISSION WITH AUTHOR THE
COMMISSION AUTHORIZED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF OVER FIVE
THOUSAND EACH RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS TO BE BUILT
WITHIN THE MANY COLORFUL
SUBDIVISIONS SPRINGING UP FROM
SAN DIEGO TO SANTA CRUZ. THE
COMMISSION ALSO PREVENTED THE
DEMOLITION OF OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED EXISTING UNITS AND
COLLECTED OVER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN INCLUDE FEET. BUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WAS AS
CONTROVERSIAL BAN AS IT IS NOW
SO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
SENATOR HENRY MELLO CARRIED A
BILL THAT REPEALED THE
COMMISSION AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITY. AND EXPRESSLY
AUTHORIZED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DEMOLISH EXISTING AFFORDABLE
UNITS IN THE FOCUS ON. IT
PROHIBITED THE COMMISSION FROM
REQUIRING HOUSING PROGRAMS AND
HEALTHY PEAS. BUT AUTHORIZED
DEVELOPERS TO GET OUT FROM
UNDER EARLIER CONDITIONS
REQUIRING THEM TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE UNITS. AS A RESULT
ONLY THIRTEEN HUNDRED OF THE
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS WERE EVER
BUILT. IMAGINE WHAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD LOOK LIKE TODAY IF THE
COMMISSION HAD BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUE PROTECTING AND
PROMOTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE CALL HOLD ON. FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
WOULD RESTORE THE COMPLEX
AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICIES.
AND REPEAL THE PROHIBITION ON
HOUSING POLICIES IN L. C. P. IT
WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE COMMISSION
TO PROVIDE FOR GREATER
RESIDENTIAL DENSITY IN URBAN
AREAS NOT AT RISK OF WILDFIRE
PERSONALIZED. FINALLY IT WOULD
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
UPDATE THEIR L. C. P. TO
REFLECT RECENT CHANGES TO
EIGHTY YOU LAWS. SOMETHING THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN
RECOMMENDING SINCE TWO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN A SERIES OF
GUIDANCE MEMOS. MEMBERS THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO UNDO THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST AND
RESTORE THE COSTA LACKS
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
COASTLINE THAT IS NOT THE ONLY
ACCESSIBLE. TO ALL BUT LIVABLE
AS WELL I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I'M AVAILABLE TO QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISS
CHRISTY- NEXT LEAD SPORT
WITNESS. PLEASE PROCEED. LIKE
THE MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS BUT THERE'S LIKE AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR PEOPLE
ORGANIZED FOR WESTSIDE RENEWAL
A. K. POWER NOR MEMBERS ALSO
SUPPORT AB FIVE HUNDRED WE WERE
FOUND IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
AND ONE SIDE LA TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT THAT GENTRIFICATION
WHICH HAVE AND LOW INCOME
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY WITHIN OUR
COASTAL ZONE. AND WE OUGHT TO
CREATE AND PRESERVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ARE GRASSROOTS MEMBERS
REGULARLY ENGAGE WITH LOCAL
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS CITY
PLANNING COMMISSION DOWN THE
COASTAL COMMISSION AND ITS
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING TO
EXPLAIN NORM GRASSROOTS MEMBERS
THAT THE COASTAL COMMISSION
CANNOT CONSIDER PORTABLE
HOUSING THE PRIMARY REASON OUR
MEMBERS ENGAGED IN LAND USE
CONVERTIBLE HOUSING IS IN FACT
BECAUSE THE RESOURCE AND SHOULD
BE TREATED AS SUCH BY THE
COMMISSION AND- UNFORTUNATELY
THEY'RE RESTRICTED BY LAW AND
CAN'T DO THAT. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU RECALL THAT YOU
SUPPORT AS WELL SO THAT OUR
MEMBERS CAN ENGAGE THE
COMMISSION ON ASIA THAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT TO THEM ACROSS LAND
USE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN
ARKANSAS IS ON THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER LUCKY- ONE MOVE ON
OTHER. WITNESSES SINCE OF ALL
OTHERS WISHING THAT'S BY JUST
LIMITED NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
OPERATOR PLEASE CALL DO ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. FOR THE
REMOTE HEARING ROOMS. OKAY
OPERATORS TURN THE LIGHTS. WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. MORNING IS JAMIE
GO ON BEHALF OF YOUR PART THANK
YOU. PINE. FORTY SIX. ONE OF
THEM WE DON'T KNOW WITHOUT ONE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. LINE
TWENTY TWO. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI THIS IS NO COOL
COASTAL ST PETER NEVER COUNCIL
WE ALREADY PASSED A STRONG
MOTION URGING STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE HUNDRED. THANK YOU.
PINE. FIFTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME
IS JULIE KERALA'S- I AM LOOKING
MY MENTAL HEALTH COALITION- I
WANTED TO- AS BECOME SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE HUNDRED THERE'S SO MUCH
DEVELOPER INFLUENCE IN COASTAL
AREAS IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
LIVING NEAR THE COAST IS
DEFINITELY AN ASPIRATION FOR
EVERYONE- YET LOW INCOME
MINORITY COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING EXPERIENCING RAPID
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
WHERE I LIVE BAR LOGIN AS A
CULTURAL ARTS DISTRICT WITH A
MEDIAN INCOME OF THIRTY EIGHT
K. PER YEAR 92% OF OUR
POPULATION IS ELIGIBLE TO LIVE
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING. YET IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
DEVELOPING OUR OWN C. P. WE'VE
HAD THE HARDEST TIME
INTRODUCING AFFORDABLE I'M SO
SORRY WE WERE JUST WANTING TO
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION HERE I-
IN RIDLEY ALLEGEDLY PROCEEDED
JUST NEED YOUR NAME AND JUST
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
PLEASE SORRY. WE ARE IN. THANKS
SO MUCH. NINE TWENTY. HI I'M
ROBIN RUSSO I'M A COASTAL
ADVOCATE AND ELECTED OFFICIAL-
MONTHS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL AND CHAIRED BOTH
BENETTON ST PETER LANYON
COMMITTEES AND HAVE OVER TEN IN
TEN YEARS EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
ON THE GROUND WITH COSTA
PROJECT INCLUDING EIGHTY YEARS
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK
LOCAL MEMBERS SEVERAL LOS
ANGELES BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
IN SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
NONPROFIT CITIZENS FOR THEIR
DEFENSE. WHAT ABOUT HAVING OF
THE COSTA AN ARGUMENT CHRISTIAN
MONTH EIGHT INTERRUPT YOU MA'AM
THEM I CERTAINLY WE JUST GOT A
LIMIT YOU TO JUST WHETHER
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BUT WE DID GET YOUR BIOGRAPHY
AND WHO AND THE PEOPLE YOU
REPRESENT SO SUPPORT YOU IN
SUPPORT YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'M REPORTED THAT THE PARTY
BILL THANK YOU OKAY THANKS A
LOT. NEXT WITNESS IT'S JUST A
REPORT JUSTIN WHAT IS YOUR
POSITION ON THE LEGISLATION
YOUR AFFILIATION. IN YOUR NAME
PLEASE THANKS SO MUCH. NEXT WE
HAVE KNOW WHAT ELSE WITH THIS
SIR OKAY VERY GOOD- THANKS ALL
FOR UNDER- WORK WE'RE GONNA.
TOP IN AND HE ROOM OR REMOTELY.
SEEING NONE WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE'S OPERATOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITE- YET TO LEAD WITNESSES
FOR OPPOSITION AT NO I I'VE GOT
TO GET A TO LEAD WINESSES FOR
OPPOSITION I INSTANTLY OF
DEMOCRATS AND STEVE CREWS HERE
YOU WANT TO TURN TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. YES THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE DEMOCRATS WITH A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. WELL WE
AGREE WITH THE STATED GOAL OF
AB FIVE HUNDRED WHICH IS TO
PROVIDE MORE HOUSING WE DON'T
BELIEVE AB FIVE HUNDRED DOES
THAT. AS YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE PREVIOUSLY REMOVED
THE CULTURE COMMISSION POWER TO
IMPOSE HOUSING POLICY BECAUSE
OF THE INCONSISTENCY THEY
THOUGHT BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WE BELIEVE IT'S THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS JOB I TO
APPROVE HOUSING. AND WHAT WE
HAVE OFFERED OUR SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT WE BELIEVE DO
THIS. FIVE BUT UNFORTUNATELY-
WE INCORRECTLY- UNDERSTOOD THAT
THOSE AMENDMENTS- WERE
ACCEPTABLE THE AUTHOR DOES THE
MEMBERS HAVE NOT BEEN MADE YET
WE HAVE SUBMITTED THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE.
INCLUDING WANT TO SAVE YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOUSING
PRODUCTION BEEN MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CAN AND CANNOT DO WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL OPENS UP SO MUCH MORE
ON SUBJECTIVE. APPROVAL OR NON
APPROVAL WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE
HOUSING YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
CONVINCE US THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S PRIMARY GOAL IS TO
PROMOTE HOUSING- BE MORE
SPECIFIC WITH THIS BILL AND
ACCEPT OUR AMENDMENTS. AND THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WOULD REMOVE ITS
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR LISTENING. THANK YOU
MISS CARLTON MR CRUZ. YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- SPEAKERS I WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY
BEFORE I START IF YOU'RE GOOD.
PERFECT THANK YOU SIR- STEVE
CREWS WHICH CRUISE STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
REGRETTABLY OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE HUNDRED. I KNOW SOME WOMEN
WARS WELL INTENDED. HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE THAT RATHER PROMOTE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. AB FIVE HUNDRED
WOULD ACTUALLY SHIP THE
AUTHORITY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COMPRISED OF ELECTED OFFICIALS
YOUR CLOSEST RESIDENT CAN YOU
NEEDS. TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ON ELECTED STATEWIDE
BODY WITH SCARCE RESOURCES AND
LIMITED EXPERIENCE
ADMINISTERING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ISSUES. IN DOING SO AB.
FIVE HUNDRED. IN FAVOR OF THE
COSTA COMMISSION. MOREOVER
EIGHTY FIVE I WILL GRANT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION WITH
UNBRIDLED DISCRETION TO DEVELOP
HOUSING POLICY WITHOUT ANY
OTHER RESTRICTIONS OR
SAFEGUARDS CONTAINED IN THE
MAIL ACT IS BLANK CHECK RAISE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION'S POTENTIAL
POLICY RESPONSE. PARTICULARLY
LIE THE COMMISSION'S GUIDELINES
BONTA PORTABLE HOUSING PRIOR TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WHICH
CONTEMPLATE YOU POTENTIALLY
ONEROUS INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS DEVELOPED OUTSIDE
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. RENDON
SUCH BY HOUSING AT WITHOUT
LIMITING TO THE COMMISSION BUT
CREATE SUBSTANTIAL UNCERTAINTY
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPERS AS NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
COULD BE ADDED ON AN AD HOC
BASIS LATE IN THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. THANK YOU FOR YOU
KNOW. IT IT IS MEMBERS SUPPORT
MORE NOT LET HOW MUCH HOW THE
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA- OUT
ALL WRAPPED UP CHAIRMAN. AND
AGAIN WE SHARE THE GOAL OF
INCREASING THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND AVAILABILITY
HOUR WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED AB
FIVE HUNDRED THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MR
CRUISE- OPERATE LET'S GO TO A
GENERAL SUPPORT A
GENERALIZATION WITNESSES HERE.
KNOWN IN THE ROOM BUT CERTAIN
LINES. EARLY FIGURE OUT
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME WELL FIRST GO TO LINE
FORTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHARING INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
RESPECTABILITY IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE.
EIGHTEEN LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU CALPERS SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED. THANK YOU.
NEXT WHERE ONE MORE LINE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEIR LINE NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOURTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CARLA FARLEY ON
BEHALF OF MARCOS CALIFORNIA'S
BEGIN STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB
FIVE HUNDRED. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MANY OTHERS. MR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DIS- COMMENTS WILL
START CENTER HUESO AND WILL
BRING IT AROUND OR- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD-
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY IF YOU ASK
ANYBODY IN OUR STATE EVERYBODY.
WANTS US TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS THEY BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD HOMELESSNESS SHOULD NOT
EXIST BUT WHENEVER YOU PROPOSE
PUTTING HOMELESS FACILITY IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD. ABSOLUTELY
NOT I THINK ALSO OF
CALIFORNIANS ONE OF MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BUT WHEN
YOU PROPOSE PUTTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NEIGHBORHOOD
NEIGHBORHOODS ABSOLUTELY NOT IN
MY BACKYARD TYPE OF IT FEELING.
AND THAT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE
HERE IN GOVERNMENT THAT
WHENEVER WE TRY TO PROPOSE ANY
SOLUTION TO BRING. ARE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO THE STATE
THERE'S ALWAYS A GROUP THE
COMES OUT AND SAYS ABSOLUTELY
NOT WE CAN'T DO THAT I JUST
HAVEN'T FOUND A SOLUTION. THAT
MAKES EVERYONE HAPPY. BUT WE
HAVE ONE HERE THAT IS
COMPLETELY REASONABLE ONE THAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING THAT USED TO
ALREADY BE PART OF THE PROCESS
THE FACT THAT IT WAS REMOVED.
IT IS JUST A SAD PIECE OF
HISTORY IN OUR STATE THAT WE
CANNOT THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION SHOULD NOT. INFORCE
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE COASTERS ON WHAT HAS
HAPPENED. OUR COASTAL AREAS
HAVE BECOME LESS AFFORDABLE.
AND IN MANY CASES SOME SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE JOBS BE
PROVIDED IN THE COASTAL AREA
HAVE ALSO BEEN LESS WELL
REMUNERATED SO. FOUR FOUR COULD
COMMUNITIES ON THE COASTLINE
THEY DEFINITELY PROVIDE A LOT
OF LOW WAGE JOBS. BUT EVERY
SINGLE WORKER THAT COMES INTO
THE COASTAL ZONE COMES FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND THAT'S
DEFINITELY NOT GOOD FOR OUR FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S
DEFINITELY. NOT GOOD TO CREATE
AN EQUITABLE SOCIETY AND
DEFINITELY NOT GOOD TO. PROVIDE
PEOPLE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE WHEREVER THEY WANT TO LIVE
IN THE STATE. THAT'S JUST AN
ENORMOUS FAILURE OF OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT IT'S UP ENORMOUS
FAITH- FAILURE OF HOW OF PUBLIC
POLICY HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
REALLY TO SEGREGATE PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE IN TWO DIFFERENT
NEIGHBORHOODS WE HAVE. HIGH
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS IN MIDDLE
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS IN
CALIFORNIA JUST AN ENORMOUSLY
SEGREGATED STATE AND IT AND
IT'S BEEN IT'S VERY SAD AND WE
SHOULD AS POLICY MAKERS WORK.
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO LIVE
WHEREVER THEY WANT AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IT ONE ATTEND
AND GIVE THEM. THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO LIVE WHERE THEY WORK AND TOO
POTENTIALLY WALK TO WORK OR NOT
HAVE THESE ENORMOUSLY LONG
COMMUTES- SO. I APPRECIATE THIS
BILL I YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED THAT THIS IS GONNA. A
CREATE INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
COASTAL COMMISSION YES. THERE
ARE INCONSISTENCIES BECAUSE IN
MANY CASES THERE ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE NOT
IMPLEMENTING THE COAST LACKED.
THEY REFUSE TO CREATE A LOCAL
COASTAL PLAN OFTENTIMES WHEN
THERE'S A LAW ON THE BOOKS THEY
APPROVED PROJECTS TO DO NOT
CONFORM THAT'S JUST. A FACT.
AND YES THAT CREATES A CONFLICT
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WITH THE
COASTAL ACT. REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS JUST DO NOT WANT TO
DO. AND IF YOU ASK ME AND YOU
KNOW I HAVE SEEN VERY VERY
LITTLE. AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
BE BUILT IN THE COASTAL.
COASTAL ZONE. I HAVE WORKED.
AND SUCCESSFULLY TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE BUT IT WASN'T
COMMUNITIES LIKE MARTY LOGAN.
THAT JOB I HAVE OFTEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BUT
INDUSTRIAL USES AN AND PARTY
LOGAN WE HAVE TRIED TO. REZONE
AND CREATE A COMMUNITY THAT YOU
SEE AN AREA THAT USED TO BE A
COMMUNITY BUT THAT WAS ABSORBED
BY INDUSTRIAL USE IN AND BEFORE
YOU KNOW WE HAD JUNKYARDS AND
WE HAD. OF CHROME PLATING SHOPS
AND WE HAD- USES ADJUSTED NOT
MIX WITH RESIDENTIAL AND I
THINK THAT'S A CALIFORNIA STORE
IF YOU GO AROUND CALIFORNIA YOU
SEE WHERE. IF THEIR OWN ANY LOW
INCOME PEOPLE LIVE IN THE CLOSE
IT'S USUALLY IN VERY
CONTAMINATED COMMUNITIES IN THE
COAST A BUDDY IN INDUSTRY. AND
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WE CAN RESOLVE THIS BILL
COULD RESULT THAT HOPE OVER THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS I I'M
ENCOURAGED. THAT THIS BILL
COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE BECAUSE
I SERVED ON THE COAST
COMMISSION. I WAS THERE SEVERAL
YEARS AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY TIMES. IT WAS SIDE DURING
A HERE. THAT WE COULD NOT EVEN
DISCUSS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BECAUSE IT HAD BEEN STRICKEN.
FROM THE COASTAL ACT. AND HOW
MUCH OF A. FIVE A JUST A
HISTORIC. JUDICIARY OF DATA
THERE IS ON THE SUBJECT THAT'S
THERE IT'S AVAILABLE TO US NOW
IF THIS WAS REINSTATED WE CAN
GO BACK TO YEARS AND YEARS OF
CASE LAW RELATED TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE IN THE COASTAL
ZONE. THAT WOULD HELP US TO
JUDICATA FUTURE HOUSING SO THIS
IS NOT ANYTHING NEW. IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS A TOOL.
PROBABLY DIDN'T SOLVE ALL THE
WORLD'S PROBLEMS BUT IT SOLVES
SOME. AND THIS BILL WILL
PROBABLY NOT SOLVE ALL THE
WORLD'S PROBLEMS BECAUSE YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
RESISTANCE TO ANY KIND OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN THE IN
THE IN THE COASTAL ZONE OR ANY
HOUSING WHETHER FORD WILL NOT
THAT HOUSES WORKERS MIDDLE
INCOME WORKERS OR EVEN. A LOW
LOW WAGE WORKERS ANYTHING THAT
RESEMBLES THAT WILL BE OPPOSED
TO THE CULTURES ON NO MATTER
WHAT LAW IS PUT INTO PLACE BUT
HAVING THAT I THINK WILL MAKE.
AN ENORMOUS DIFFERENCE IN THEM
THAT THAT WILL DISCUSSION WILL
BE HAD AND IT WILL HOLD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE TO
APPROVING PROJECTS THAT KNOWN
NOT ONLY CONFORM TO THE STATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
BUT THEN IT ALLOWS ANOTHER
JURISDICTION THAT HAS A LOT OF
INFLUENCE TO ENSURE. THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE WORKING THANKS
PRODIGIOUSLY TO CREATE THE
HOUSING THAT THEY PROMISED TO
PROVIDE SO I THINK THIS IS ONE
MORE FULL BILL I DON'T THINK IT
NEEDS ANYTHING I'D LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE AT SOME POINT IN THIS
PROCESS AND I JUST WANT TO PLOT-
THE AUTHOR FOR HAVING THE
COURAGE REALLY TO BRING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS. THAT WILL FULFILL
ITS PROMISE THANK YOU. FOR
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO CENTER
EGGMAN- CENTER LAYERED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR THAT
IT ACTUALLY MISTER HUESO PARK
ANSWERED THE QUESTION I WAS
GOING TO ASK THE AUTHOR BUT OUR
BECAUSE- I'VE BEEN ON BOTH
SIDES ARE THE NEXT OFFICIAL
MEMBER OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION FOR EIGHT YEARS BUT
I WAS ALSO MARRIED TO TIME WE
ADOPTED A LOCAL COASTAL PLAN
AND- AT THE SAME TIME AS
RESOURCES SECRETARY FUNDED THE
UPDATE OF COUNTLESS LOCAL
COASTAL PLANTS PRIMARILY. TO
DEAL WITH SEA LEVEL RISE. AND
SO WHEN I READ THE ANALYSIS AND
READ THE LETTERS THAT CAME IN.
TO GET THE GOAL ARE OBVIOUSLY
SHARE THE GOAL I UNDERSTAND THE
BILL AND WHAT IT DOES BUT
WHAT'S NOT CLEARLY ARTICULATED.
THAT SENATOR HUESO GOD AT A BIT
IN HIS COMMENTS IS HOW DOES
THIS ACTUALLY PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND HOW
DOES THIS NOT IMPEDE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT WAS NOT CLEAR FROM
THE ANALYSIS AND SO HOW WOULD
YOU RESPOND TO THAT. THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED AND- I'D LIKE TO
SAY THAT THAT PERSON DOESN'T
ALTER SPONSORED BILL I WANTED
TO GET IN THERE AND BE IN
CONTROL OF HOW WE ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING INTO THE SPACE SIDEBAND
WRITTEN EVERY WORD I'VE
ANALYZED EVERY COMMA BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THIS IS
DONE RIGHT- WE HAVE. EXAMPLES
FROM THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WHICH I PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL WE
ACTUALLY EAT MORE ABOUT MORE
THAN A YEAR AHEAD OF THE STATE
WHEN WE STREAMLINED OUR EIGHTY
YOU REGULATIONS AND WHAT WE
FOUND WAS. IN THE PARTS OF THE
CITY OUTSIDE OF THE COASTAL
ZONE WILDLY POPULAR PEOPLE
WANTED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT
THEY WERE ON THE NEW THAT HAVE
REDUCED PERMIT TIME TO NEW THAT
WOULD HAVE REDUCED COSTS- AND
THEY WERE IN WE HAVE HUNDREDS
OF THE WERE WE OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT HAVE HAD. THOSE PERMITS
COMING INTO THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO THE PART OF THE CITY THAT
IS INSIDE THE COASTAL ZONE WE
HAD SIX DURING THAT SAME TIME
PERIOD AND WE TALK TO THOSE AND
DEVELOP INDIVIDUALS AND WE
TALKED THE OTHER. INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE BEEN TRYING TO THINK
ABOUT 1100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT INSIDE THE COASTAL
ZONE. KC YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF
THE ADDITIONAL BARRIER AND IT
IS IMPORTANT TO YOU BUT THE
ADDITIONAL PART OF THE PROCESS
TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH A CD P.
REVIEW. THEY KNOW THAT TAKES
TIME THEY KNOW THAT THE STAFF
FOR THE COLUMBUS ALREADY. AYE
SIR JERRY BROWN USE AN ACRONYM
GO. TO PRISON. WHAT DOES HE ACT.
MEAN THAT YOU'RE SAID. THE- THE
EIGHTY. OF CDP OR SOMETHING
THAT. PER BECAUSE THAT THANK
YOU ALL PART THAT WE TO GO. AND
I. THE CLOSER TO. DESERVE MORE
RE. BECAUSE THEY BACK LAW
WITHIN OF STAFF TODAY. BUT
THESE ARE VERY SIMPLE. TYPES
THAT WE KNOW HELP CONTRIBUTE.
TO THE HOUSING STOCK THAT WE
NEED FOR MIDDLE AND LOWER
INCOME CALIFORNIANS THEY OUGHT
TO BE EXPEDITED. AT THE TOP OF
THE COASTAL COMMISSION THEY
SAY. REMEMBER THAT WE HAVE.
VOTER AND ENTITLED MANDATES TO
REALLY PROTECT OUR COASTAL
RESOURCES PROTECT COASTAL
ACCESS BUT FOR ME WHEN I'M
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH
THEM. IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
VISITORS SERVING ACCOMMODATIONS
AS A LAND USE BODY. THAT
ALREADY HAS REGULATORY POWERS
IT'S IMPORTANT THEY'RE
BALANCING RESIDENTIAL INTEREST
THERE- FOR HOW WE ARE MAKING
SURE. THAT THE POSTAL ON
DEVELOPMENT PLANS WHICH EVERY
CITY OR EVERY JURISDICTION
SHOULD BE SUBMITTING AS WELL.
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
UNDERLYING CITY ZONING SITTING.
HOUSING ELEMENTS SO. I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ADDITIONAL ON
TIME I CHECK AND BALANCE THAT
WE HAVE FOR SPECIAL ZONE OF OUR
STATE. HE AND I'M NOT SURE THAT
TOTALLY. ADDRESSES IT WILL BE
TRIED A DIFFERENT WAY. BECAUSE
IN MY HOME AREA IF SOMEBODY
DOESN'T GET WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY USED A LOCAL COASTAL PLAN
TO APPEAL IT TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND DRAG OUT THE
DEVELOPMENT. AND THAT'S NOT IN
THIS FOR EIGHTY USER OTHER
THINGS NOW. BUT IT WILL HAVE
THIS. HOW ARE YOU CONFIDENT.
THAT THIS WILL EXPEDITE AND NOT
ALLOW PEOPLE ANOTHER BITE AT
THE APPLE TO DELAY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. OKAY THAT'S WHAT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND CLICK USE AS A
SENATOR SO IT MAY NOT BE IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT IT IS IN THE BILL.
IN ON PAGE SEVEN THAT ACTUALLY
DOES DIRECT. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO UPDATE THEIR-
THEIR STREAMLINED PERMITTING
PROCEDURES FOR EIGHTY YEARS
JUNIOR EIGHTY YEARS A 100%
AFFORDABLE UNITS. AND SUPPORT
OF HOUSING UNITS AS WELL. SO
SHALL. BE PROCESSED BY THE
COMMISSION AND DOT WITH RESPECT
TO ONE OF THE ARE. TESTIMONY I
HAPPEN WORKING WITH FOR SOME-
MONTHS. THERE IS ACTUALLY L.
DIAZ FOR TWO THINGS ONE OF
THOSE IS HERE IN THE BILL WHICH
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION TO
PROCESS AND APPROVING THEM IT
WITHIN THE TIME LIMIT
SPECIFIED. IN CERTAIN SECTIONS
OF THE OF THE CODE ON SO THEY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS A GUARANTEE AND THIS CASE IS
A LINES WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S ASSESSING PROCESS
TO PROCESS- THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. I THINK THAT THERE'S
ANOTHER BITE AT THE APPLE BUT
YOUR BILL IS LIMITING HOW THE
BITE AT THE APPLE CAN BE TAKEN
SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. I'M NOT
SURE I STREAMLINING OR LIMITING
THE NUMBER OF TIME I'M TRYING
TO GET. AT WHAT. I DO KNOW BE
WE'VE DONE A LOT IN THIS
LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO.
PROMOTE A STREAMLINING OF
CERTAIN HOUSING NO NO I KNOW
THAT I KNOW THAT AND THAT
EXISTS IN LAW. RIGHT AND YOU
ARE ADDING ANOTHER PIECE OF THE
LAW THAT EXISTS IN LAW FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IT DOESN'T
EXIST FOR THE- FOR THE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT PROCESS OR
LOCAL COASTAL PLAN. YES AND BUT
MY QUESTION IS ONE IT NOW WOULD
EXIST IF WE APPROVE THIS BILL
FOR THE LOCAL COASTAL PLAN.
DOES THAT IS THAT CONSISTENT
WITH THE STREAMLINING AND
DOESN'T GIVE SOMEBODY A BITE AT
THE APPLE BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
NOW TO DELAY THE HOUSING. THAT
IS OE. AND WHEN I THOUGHT I
HEARD YOU SAY. IS THAT YOU UP
SOMETHING IN THE BILL THAT
LIMITS THE ABILITY AND TIME
LINES. TO APPEAL OR DO
SOMETHING WHICH- WOULD MAKE THE
CASE THAT YOU'RE LIMITING THE
ADDITIONAL BITE OF THE APPLE
I'M TRYING TO HELP YOU HERE.
AND I'M TRYING TO GET YOU TO
TELL US CLEARLY HOW THAT'S
TRUE. I THINK IT IS TRUE
BECAUSE ACTUALLY WHAT THIS DOES
IS THIS PACKS BUT I AM REQUIRES
THE COMMISSION TO PROCESS THESE
MOD MINISTERIAL LEE. OUT WITHIN
A SPECIFIED TIMELINE. THE AND
IS THAT A CITY PERMIT WITH THE
COASTAL OVER LIFE GENERATES
EXPEDITING VAT. IT'S NOT ADDING
A SECOND COASTAL STREAMLINING.
THAT IS ADDITIONALTIME EVEN
THOUGH IT STREAMLINED RIGHT AND
BACK TO MY CITY OF SAN DIEGO
EXAMPLE THAT WAS THE PROBLEM
WITH MANY HOMEOWNERS AS THEY
KNEW THAT THEY WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO POSSIBLY A ONE OR TWO YEAR
ON STAFF FOR YOU BECAUSE
THEY'RE STILL BACK LOG. ON BUT
WHY SHOULD I GO TO THE BACK F
THE LINE THESE ARE EASILY THERE
THERE'S NO. IMPACT IN
SOMEBODY'S BACKYARD THERE'S YOU
KNOW THESE ARE NEEDED HOUSING
TYPES OF SHOULD BE EXPEDITED.
AND THEN THERE'S- I'M I'M GONNA
TAKE YOU AT YOUR WORD ON THAT
THE TO THE SECOND ISSUE IS
THERE'S A UNIQUE THING IN THE
COASTAL ACT. AND IN THE PROCESS
AND THE UNIQUE THING IS. IS
THAT THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COASTAL COMMISSION GETS TO
DECIDE. IF AN APPEAL WAS. WITH
MERIT AND FORWARDED ON TO THE
COMMISSION. SO PART OF YOUR-
GIVING. THE IF SOMEBODY WAS A
FRUIT. APPEAL AN EIGHTY. THAT
THE ACOSTA. DIRECTOR BE M. TO
DECIDE THAT IS NOT A VALID
APPEAL OPENED AT THAT AS A
BACKSTOP TO THE EXPEDITING VAT
IS. THE STORY OF HERS YES BUT
I'D LIKE TO ALLOW MY TO-
WITNESS TO BE ABLE TO. MAYBE
TALK TO A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THEIR
INTERNAL PROCESS YOU MEAN SIR
CHRISTIE. YOU MEAN SERRA
CHRISTIE PACIFIST ON JUST SAID
YOU'RE WITNESSING YOU HAD A FEW
WITNESSES YES THAT'S OKAY. I'M
FINE WITH HER ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION A FEW STONE LET'S TURN
THE LINE. MISS CHRISTY ARE YOU
STILL WITH US. YES I AM DO YOU
WANT TO JUMP IN HERE. SURE AND
THAT SHORT ANSWER TO YOUR MOST
RECENT QUESTION SENATOR WHERE
IT IS YES THAT'S EXISTING LAWS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DOES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT A- AND
APPEAL AS FRIVOLOUS. SHE BEYOND
THAT- IF IT'S NOT DEEMED
PATENTLY FRIVOLOUS AT THE
OUTSET IT GOES TO THE
COMMISSION FOR WHAT'S CALLED A
SUBSTANTIAL ISSUE HEARING WHERE
IN THE COMMISSION CONFIRMS
WHETHER OR NOT THE APPEAL
RAISES A SUBSTANTIAL ISSUE ONE
OF THE COSTA LACK SO- AND-
THEN. LET ME ASK YOU FOLLOW
QUESTION IS THERE SOMETHING
AUTHOR OF THE BILL COMES DUE.
R. TO SORT OF. PLEASE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IN A GOOD
POSITION AND DETERMINING THAT-
THING IS FRIVOLOUS BASED ON
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. WELL I
WOULD SAY- THE EXISTING LAW
COVERS THAT- IF THERE'S A WAY
TO POTENTIALLY ADD SOME
LANGUAGE TO MAKE THAT MORE
CLEAR WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR OR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. BUT AT THIS POINT
YEAH BUT THE STATUTE AS
WRITTEN. COVERS THAT- YOUR ONE
NO THERE'S MORE STOPS FOR THIS
BILL AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
DID YOU JUST CONSULT WITH THE
AUTHOR AND- AND MAKE SURE
THAT'S THE CASE AND MISTER
CHAIR ON MY OWN TIME- I WOULD
JUST SAY I THINK THAT'S THE
CENTRAL ISSUE HERE. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO WORK
TOWARD IS MAKING SURE THIS IS
NOT AN IMPEDIMENT- BECAUSE I
JUST WATCHING IT JUST HAPPENED
WITHIN AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
PROPOSAL IN THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ WHERE. IT WAS APPEALED TO
THE COMMISSION ON A HIKE LIMIT
BUT THE HAWKS TAKING EIGHT FEET
DOWN WOULD HAVE STRIPPED THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FROM THE
PROJECT AND SO. IT I'M JUST
CONCERNED THERE'S NOT SOMETHING
IN IT FOR IN THIS BILL THAT IS
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE THAT
IT IS ANOTHER BITE AT THE APPLE
FOR PEOPLE THAT. WANT TO GET IT
THIS AND SO I HOPE AS YOU MOVE
ON HE WILL CONSIDER THAT AND I
THINK. I RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
LOOK AT HOW THIS IS IMPLEMENTED
IF IT IN FACT PASSES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO NOT. COME TO
AFFECT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THE
THING YOU LOOK AT IS JUST
PEOPLE USING. AMANDA SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS USING C. QUOTE
TO DECIDE WHETHER THE OAKLAND A
SHOULD RELOCATE TO SAN JOSE
THAT WAS NOT AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUE. IT SO I'M JUST CONCERNED
THAT PEOPLE WOULD USE THIS IN A
WAY THAT HAS THE OPPOSITE
IMPACT IN TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THAT SO. YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT I THINK
THAT'S THE PRISM WITH WHICH-
YOU SHOULD LOOK AT THIS AS IT
MOVES ALONG. THANKS FOR DOCTOR
ME MR CHANNEL OF COURSE VERY
INSIGHTFUL COMMENTARY AND A LOT
OF DEEP EXPERIENCE ON THIS
COMMITTEE- INCLUDING FROM THE
AUTHOR ON THIS ISSUE AND I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE BILL
WILL IF IT MOVES FOR TODAY IT'S
GOING TO. GOVERNMENT'S FINANCE.
I BELIEVE IN AND HOUSING AFTER
THAT. WE WILL- THE HOUSING
COMMITTEES I. IT WILL BE HER
GUYS. ONE HEARING WITH CAN
HOUSING- BUT I WOULD JUST ADD
TO THE TO THE COLLEGE WE HEAR
THAT- THAT. WELL YOU WELL YOU
DON'T LOOK ONE TO SEE ANY
CONSEQUENCES OF NEW PROCESS
BECOME BEING SORT OF MISUSED
EXPLOITED ALSO WOULD POINT OUT
THAT NOTHING IN THIS MEASURE AS
I UNDERSTAND IT- CONTRAVENES
ANY OF THE EXISTING PROCESS
SEES OR PROTECTIONS IN TERMS OF
PERMITTING- ACT COASTAL SO
THOSE WHO ARE CONCERNED SAY
ABOUT- ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE HABITAT AREAS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT NON HAZARDOUS USES
AND I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT ON
FOCUSING ON WILDFIRE RISK- THAT
THAT NOTHING IN THIS WOULD
CONTRAVENE THOSE PROCESSES
IMPEDING ACCESS FOR INSTANCE IT
WOULDN'T BE THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WOULD SOMEHOW TRUMP-
ONE OF THOSE OTHER. KEY SORT OF
CORE COASTAL COMMISSION
CONSIDERATIONS BUT THAT THERE
MAY BE- AS THIS IS IMPLEMENTED-
MORE PUSH WINNER WHEN IT SOME
NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IS
PROPOSED FOR THAT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT TO BE MORE
AFFORDABLE I THINK THAT THAT
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR DOWN IN
IMPERIAL BEACH AND CHULA VISTA-AND LOGAN I I'VE BEEN IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO AND I. YEAH I
THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M
SEEING ATTENTION ESPECIALLY
FROM THE OPPOSITION TO IS
HAVING THAT INCLUSIONARY
ELEMENT. HAVING AFFORDABILITY
ELEMENT IS REALLY- WHERE
THERE'S GOING TO BE TENSION BUT
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
NAVIGATING ALL THIS BRIEFLY-
AND THAT YOU'RE SENSITIVE STILL
TO THE UNDERLYING. INTEGRITY
THE COASTAL ACT AS WELL THAT'S
THE PURVIEW THIS COMMITTEE WERE
NOT THE HOUSING COMMITTEE BUT-
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE- FROM A
RESOURCES PERSPECTIVE. ANYTHING
THAT SUDDENLY THROWS THAT OUT
THE WINDOW AND SAYS YOU KNOW
IT'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF- YOU KNOW AN
ENDANGERED GROVE- BUT I THINK
WHAT WHAT WHAT I'M HEARING YOU
SAY IS IF I NOTHER STADIUMS
GOING UP RIGHT ON THE COAST WHY
IN THAT STADIUM ALSO THINK
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS GOING INTO THAT
COMMUNITY- IF ANOTHER MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT IS GOING DOWN INTO
IMPERIAL BEACH IS IT GONNA BE-
YOU KNOW. SUPER HIGH END MARKET
RAIDER THEY GONNA TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT- SOME OF THE OTHER
FACTORS ARE NOT TO INITIATE A
NEW LAND USE PROCESS PER SE OR
OPEN UP SOME NEW OTHER
PERMITTING BUT REALLY- WITHIN
EXISTING CITY P. PROCESSING-
TOOK TO REALLY PUT THIS THUMB
ON THE SCALE SO YOU HAVE TO
CONSIDER THIS FACTOR AND I
THINK THAT EQUITY PIECES. IS
WISE AND- I THINK YOU'VE GOT A
PRETTY GOOD BALANCE HERE SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE MEASURE
TODAY- I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAD
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ARE. COMING
FROM CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION- AND MAYBE IF THE
AUTHOR- CAN'T I DON'T. I THINK
YOU CAN ANSWER IT BUT IF YOU
CAN'T I'M SURE THE TWO PEOPLE
WITH PREVIOUS CALLS TO QUESTION
EXPERIENCE WOULD BE ABLE TO-
THE BILL SAYS THAT. THE THAT
TIME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO
REQUIRE A COASTAL PLAN AND
ADOPTED BY JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. IS THAT LENGTH OF
TIME SUFFICIENT MEMORY AT THE
END OF TWENTY ONE SO TWO YEARS
IS THAT LENGTH OF TIME
SUFFICIENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROW SO IT SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT
FOR JUST THE PURPOSES OF
AMENDING AND THE LANGUAGE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE STREAMLINING FOR
THESE HOUSING TYPES. WHICH THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE SAMPLE
LANGUAGE. BY JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO HAVE A NARROW
FOCUSED. LCP AMENDMENT TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THE TERMS OF THE
BILL. I AM WITH MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR LAYERED LCP IS SORT
LOCAL COASTAL PLAN HERE THANK
YOU. I GOT INTO MY BILL RIGHT
WORD THAT. EVERY SO YOU TO TALK
TO US LIKE. RIGHT I RESPECT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY JUST JUST TO CLARIFY THE
WHEN YOU SAY. STREAMLINED AND I
WANT TO WE'RE GOING TO PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. THERE'S NO
INTENT HERE TOO WHEN IT COMES
TO ISSUE SAY OF SUBSTANTIALITY.
TO DIMINISH OR CONTRAVENE ANY
OF THE UNDERLYING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS IN THE COASTAL ACT-
CASH- ACCESS ALL THOSE
HAZARDOUS ISSUES ABSOLUTELY NOT
NO COULD BE IN CONFLICT WITH
THOSE- THOSE. REQUIREMENTS VERY
GOOD OKAY- I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION IF THERE'S NO FURTHER.
SO SO THAT'S A MOTION. FROM
SENATOR HUESO WHO ALSO HAS TO
BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR IN
THE MOTION WOULD BE DO PASSED
AS AMENDED. THE FIRST AMENDED
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE- SOME
MEMBER DO WANTED TO A CLOSE I
REALLY APPRECIATE ON THE- THAT
THE KNOWLEDGE BASE THE SUPPORT
ON THE QUESTIONS WHICH I SHARE.
THAT CONCERN AS WELL AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS- FINE
TUNE I WILL BE DOING THAT WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS WOULD BE ON
FUTURE STOP THE COMMITTEES AND
THEIR CONSULTANTS AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AND OUT
SHOULD THIS BECOME LAW IT
CERTAINLY WOULD BE WATCHING
CLOSELY ON HOW IT IMPLEMENTS.
TO MAKE SURE A CHEESY INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS DISCUSSION I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ENERGY
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE- A. B.
AB FIVE HUNDRED- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE STERN HI STERN ALRIGHT
JONES JONES NO ALLEN ALLEN HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROWTH
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG HUESO HI
HUESO ARE A LAYERED HI LAYERED
ALL RIGHT LOAN. OKAY THAT'S GOT
FIVE VOTES WE WILL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION DAY
MISTER CHAIR YES NOW THAT WE
HAVE A QUORUM WOULD YOU
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
PROPOSED CONSENT AGENDA I WOULD
INDEED AND I WOULD MOVE TO
PROPOSE CONSENT. PUTS TAKE THAT
UP CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM ONE AB SIXTY
TWO FILE ITEM FIVE AB THREE
FIFTEEN FILE ITEM SIX AB FOUR
THIRTY ONE FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
FIVE SEVEN NINE FILE ITEM TEN
AB SEVEN EIGHT ONE. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB EIGHT OH FOUR FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY. SIX STERN HI
STERN ALL RIGHT JONES JONES ALL
RIGHT ALLEN. EIGHT AND SENATE.
ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN EGGMAN
HIGHGROVE GROUP I HERTZBERG
HUESO. HUESO RA LAYERED LAYERED
I LIVE ALONE. OKAY THAT'S GOOD
VOTES WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CHAIRWOMAN
RIVAS I THINK YOU- I THINK
YOU'RE UP HERE READY FOR US.
FILE ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE. YOU'RE FOLLOWING
ALONG MEMBERS. FORMER PLEASE-
WELCOME TO THE CANADIAN PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS SUMMARIZED
ON PAGES SIX THROUGH NINE OF
THE ANALYSIS AND BANK CATHERINE
FROM YOUR TEAM FOR HER WORK ON
THIS BILL. AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
COURT DATE STATE EFFORTS TO
HELP URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES COMBAT EXTREME HEAT
BY CREATING THE EXTREME HEAT
AND COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
PROGRAM. UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
THE PROGRAM ESTABLISHES
GUIDELINES FOR COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS AND HELPS LOCAL
ENTITIES. IMPLEMENT MEASURES
THAT REDUCE EXTREME HATE. THE
FIVE HOTTEST YEARS ON RECORD
HAVE BEEN 201-620-2020 NINETEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HAVE WITNESSED
READ BREAKING WAVE. THAT HAVE
LED TO ME POWER OUT. IN IN. AND
MORE INTENSE WILD. AT THE
REPRESENT OF A LEAD TO SAID.
LATINO CAN. THESE ARE MORE THAN
JUST CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES
THEY'RE ALSO INVITED MENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUES. A RECENT-
POLITICAL ARTICLE ILLUSTRATED
THAT IF YOU WERE TOOK OVER LIKE
A MAP OF CORONAVIRUS HOT SPOTS
AND EXTREME HEAT SPOTS THE MAP
WOULD BE VIRTUALLY THE SAME.
AREAS THAT EXPERIENCE EXTREME
HEAT OFTEN HAVE LARGE EXPANSES
OF CONCRETE LESS GREENERY
HIGHER DENSITY HOUSING IN LOWER
AVERAGE INCOMES AND POOR HEALTH
STATUS. SENATORS DEATHS COULD
BE PREVENTED IF WE WERE TO
INVEST IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO MITIGATE EXTREME HATE.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A GROWING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS CONTINUED
INACTION WILL INCREASE
HARDSHIPS ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING DUE
TO THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC. IT ALSO
NEGATIVELY AFFECTS THE QUALITY
OF THE PUBLIC'S OVERALL HEALTH.
AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE WILL BRING
EQUITY TO CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES AND GIVE THEM A
FIGHTING CHANCE TO BEAT THE
HEAT. TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I HAVE AND
YOU GET WHAT. POLICY AND
OUTREACH CONSULTANT. AT CLIMATE
RESULTS AND DAVID EISENMAN
DIRECTOR OF THE UCLA CENTER FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND DISASTERS.
THANK YOU SEE A MEMBER-
WITNESSES YOU JUST TO REMIND
YOU OF THREE MINUTES TOTAL PER
SIDE- SO MISTER WORKED AT. WITH
CLIMBERS ALL YOU WANT TO KICK
OFF HERE. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS INCLUDED WITH THAT. I'M THE
POLICY NOT RETURN PHONE
PROCLAIM RESULT. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE. THE EXTREME
HEAT AND COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
PROGRAM. I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
THREE KEY POINTS FIRST. HE IS A
BIG PROBLEM IN THE STATE'S
RESPONSE THIS PIECEMEAL BERMAN
ADEQUATE. CAN AB FIVE YOU'D
FIND ADDRESSES THE GROWING
PROBLEM BY. REQUIRING
COORDINATION OF EXISTING WORK
FOR MORE THAN A DOZEN SPEAKING
SHE'S CURRENTLY WORKING IN
SILOS. AND TRIGGERING THE
DEMAND FOR LOCAL COMPREHENSIVE
HE GOT SOME. THIRD PASSAGE OF
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE TWO
CENTRAL TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY BLACK
AND BROWN AND OTHER VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. FROM THE
INCREASING THREATS OF EXTREME
HEAT. THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
THEIR PERSONAL STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE FAITH BASED GROUPS AND
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS. I
THANK YOU CHURCH TURN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MR
WHERE THE- MR EISENMAN. YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU'RE UP OKAY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STERN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DAVID LIDERMAN I'M A
PHYSICIAN A UCLA HEALTH
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT THE
UCLA DAVID GEFFEN SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE DIRECTOR OF THE UCLA
CENTER FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MASTERS AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE UCLA CENTER FOR HEALTHY
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS. AND I'M HERE
TO ASK YOUR VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. IN AN
AVERAGE YEAR EXTREME HEAT CAUSE
MORE DEATHS THAN HURRICANE
FLOODS TORNADOES AND LIGHTNING
COMBINED. AND SOME POPULATIONS
TAKE A LARGER THREATEN OTHERS.
THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT THE
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY OUR GREATEST RISK FROM
EXTREME HEAT IT INCLUDES
SENIORS ESPECIALLY THOSE LIVING
ALONE MEMBERS IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES PEOPLE CRYING
DISEASES OUTDOOR WORKERS AND
YOUNG CHILDREN AND INFANTS. FOR
MANY OF THESE AVAILABLE PEOPLE
THE BIGGEST DRIVER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO AIR
CONDITIONED OR COOL SPACES.
EVEN IF ONLY FOR A FEW HOURS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE WAYS TO
PREVENT HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES
AND DEATHS. MY OWN WORK
PUBLISHED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OTHER USUALLY RESEARCHERS HAVE
SHOWN THAT HAVING ACCESS TO
COOL SPACES SAVE LIVES. EVEN
THE USE OF REFLECTIVE SURFACES
OR TREE SHAPE CAN SAVE ONE FOR
LIVES OTHERWISE LOST IN Q. TWO
IF I REDUCING NEIGHBORHOOD AND
HOME TEMPERATURES. OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED STRATEGIES FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS TO INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS SUCH AS COMMUNITY
CENTERS ARE IMPORTANT WAYS TO
SHOW THE RESILIENCE AND
ADAPTATION ARE LOCALLY DRIVEN.
TOGETHER THE SOLUTIONS NOT ONLY
PROVIDE DAILY BENEFITS AND
RESOURCES BUT ALSO SAVES LIVES.
TAKE REALLY. IN LOW INCOME AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
CALIFORNIA ALWAYS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF RESPOND TO CLIMATE
CHANGE EXTREME HEAT IT'S ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS CALIFORNIANS PAY.
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE CAN
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING
LEADERSHIP CREATING A FRAMEWORK
AND PROVIDING THE FUNDS
NECESSARY. SCALE INCLUDING
OPTIONS. INNOVATIVE RESILIENT
SOLUTIONS AND ADDRESS A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH EQUITY
URGENCY THANKS I RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THE PORT OF EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN YOUR
IN YOUR WORK- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT- JUST NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE
LEGISLATION. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. OR IN ANY
OF OUR REMOTE ROOMS. SO- WILL
TO THE LAW. OPERATOR THANK YOU
TO STATE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
FORMER FIRST ONLINE. FORTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING SURE NUMBER
OF NATALIE KNOCKED ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. BUT A LINE FIFTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS DOESN'T WORK
NOT JUST WITH A CLIENT CENTER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I AM. THIRTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RECALL
MASTRODONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND SPOCK THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL WE NEED TO
CONSTANTIUS STEP UP OUR
INVESTMENTS TO ADAPTING TO
EXTREME HEAT WITH URBAN
GREENING AND URBAN FORESTRY OR
ACCEPT A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
SOMETHING PEOPLE DIED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU. PINE. THIRTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS AREN'T ABLE ONE PAIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH. PINE.
FIFTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN SENATOR BUKOLA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND PART. THANK YOU.
LINE. TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
CAN DOWN DON'T ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK. PINE. SIXTY THREE. HELLO
SACRAMENTO SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS THEY'RE
TALKING ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANKS SO MUCH. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT. WHAT THE AMERICA
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY SIX. WHAT
I MEAN I KNOW WITHOUT ON
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY NINE. JAMIE GO
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BLIND SIXTY
FIVE. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
KIM DELFINO REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS JEAN
HURTS CALLING IN TODAY ON
BEHALF OF COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NO FURTHER LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME. OKAY GREAT- LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE
ANY IN THE ROOM SEEING NONE
REMOTELY SEEING NONE. MODERATOR
WOULD YOU MIND TURNING THE
LINES OF ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY. I DON'T
HAVE ANY OFFICIAL YOU LIED. THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO JOIN
THE QUEUE THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
FORMER FIRST ALIGNED. SIXTY SIX
ZERO. HI SORRY I THINK I WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO FOR- SUPPORT MY
NAME IS DAVID ADDED VETO WITH A
RP CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YEAH WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT WOULD BE
NOTED. YEP LINE. TWENTY FIVE.
HI I ACTUALLY ALSO MEANT TO BE
IN THE COURT MY NAME IS KELLY
TURNER AND WITH THE LEFT IN
CENTER FOR INNOVATION AT UCLA
WE WILL BE CROSS POLLINATING
NOW BUT YES OKAY THANK YOU
MOVING ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
THIS IS THE TIME TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO LEGISLATION WE
APPRECIATE THE OTHERS. THE LINE
FIFTY SEVEN- YES- CENTER
MEMBERS COMMITTEE IS GYPSY
RESUME HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
ASPHALT PAVEMENT ASSOCIATION HI
THIS IS THE OLDEST AND LARGEST
CONSTRUCTION TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOCUSING EXCLUSIVELY ON ASPHALT
PAVEMENT PORTION WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED THE
PROVISION INCLUDING COOL
PAVEMENTS WELL WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE AN OBJECTION REGARDING
THAT WHAT THE- BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO THERE'S A
GROWING BODY OF EVIDENCE THAT
COOL PAVEMENTS REALLY REPLY ON
REFLECTIVITY AS A WAY OF
ACHIEVING THOSE RESULTS AND THE
PROBLEM IS WHEN YOU REFLECT.
THE HEAT THAT HITS THE GROUND
IT GOES UP TO THE BUT
SURROUNDING BUILDINGS THEREFORE
USUALLY HEATING THE SURROUNDING
BUILDINGS AND SURROUNDING AREAS
THEREBY REQUIRING MORE ENERGY
TO COOL THOSE BUILDINGS SO
SOMETIMES END UP WITH A SORT OF
A PERVERSE EFFECT AND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH SO
WE'RE CONCERNED WITH THAT AND
THE L. THE ASSOCIATES REMAINS
OPPOSED LESS AMENDED FOR
REMOVED THE PROVISION
ADDRESSING COOL PAVEMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY VERY
GOOD. THANK MISS SIEVERS ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. NO OTHER
LINES AND- OKAY- WELL THAT THAT
THAT IS THE END OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THEN- I'LL JUST SAY
AT THE GATES I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO HAVE YOU IS THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AT A MOMENT WHERE HE-
IS THE- THE SECRET KILLER OUT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT WHEN
WE'RE HITTING A HUNDRED TWENTY
DEGREES AND SILMAR PROCLAIM
OUR- YOU KNOW CANOGA PARK- THIS
ISN'T. THIS IS ACTUALLY TAKING
LIVES NOW WE DON'T ALWAYS
ACCOUNT FOR IT WE DON'T ALWAYS
UNDERSTAND THE FULL IMPACT OF
HEAT BUT- I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE IDEA THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE A DEDICATED
SINGLE MINDED EFFORT THROUGH
THIS LENS AND I THINK THAT THE
POSITIONING OF THIS MEASURE
WITHIN- OPR AND THE IG CARP
PROCESS AND SORRY FOR THE
ANALOGY BUT WITHIN THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH OTHER
SOMETHING CALLED THE INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY PROGRAMS OF THIS
WOULD SET UP ITS OWN- OFFICE
UNDER THAT PROGRAM. THE BIG THE
ONLY CONCERN I HAVE IS I DON'T
WANT THESE PLANS TO END UP ON A
SHELF WE WANT WE WANT THIS TO
TAKE EFFECT I APPRECIATE THE
REPORTING FUNCTION AND THIS
YEAR WE'RE GONNA BE BUDGETING
IN THIS AREA AS WELL- I'M
HOPING GOING FORWARD THAT. WE
JUST. WE'VE WE FOCUS ON THOSE
OUTCOMES AND REALLY TRYTO MAKE
SURE THAT WE USE THIS
LEGISLATION AS THE WAY TO HOLD
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FOLLOWING
THROUGH- I THINK IT'S GOT ALL
THE TOOLS TO DO THAT IT'LL BE
ON US. GOING FOR TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN BUT WHEN I THINK OF. THE
IMPACT ON INFANT MORTALITY ON
PREMATURE BIRTH- THE NEW STUDY
THAT JUST CAME OUT ON THE
IMPACT OF PREGNANT WOMEN AT
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN WEEKS-
THERE'S NEW RESEARCH THAT
EMERGED. ON SUICIDE RATES AND
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
ACTUALLY JUMPING DURING
1010 DEGREES JUMP SO THAT YOU
TO HAVE A- I THINK IT'S A 5%
UPTICK IN SELF HARM FIVE POINT
8% UPTICK IN SELF HARM. AND
SUICIDE. AND INTENTIONALLY AN
INJURY IN HOMICIDE UP SEVEN
POINT NINE PERCENT. FOR THE
FIRST 10 DEGREES JUMP IN
TEMPERATURE. THESE THESE ARE
VERY REAL EFFECTS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT AREN'T REALLY
MEASURED AS A CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUE PER SE BUT YOU BROUGHT
THAT HUMANITY TO THIS SO. I AM
LOOKING FORWARD IF THE BILL IS
FOR TODAY TO BE ADDED ON TO
THIS AND BE YOUR YOUR CO AUTHOR
AND CO CHAMPION ON THIS
MEASURE- THEY DON'T CALL IT.
GLOBAL WARMING- FOR LACK OF A
WE STARTED FOCUSING ON SEA
LEVEL RISE IN WILDFIRE BUT THE
HEAT IT'S ALL ABOUT PIZZA THANK
YOU FOR YOU AND YOUR SPONSORS
FOR BRINGING HE HAD TO LIKE.
THE CENTER EGGMAN. BUT YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR. BRING THIS PHOTO
S. MEMBER AT I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS. IT SO WE KNOW THE
ALL THE ISLAND IN MOSTLY IN IN
CITY- THIS IS SO IS THERE GOING
TO BE AN OVERALL PLAN THAT WILL.
WILK ASSESS WHERE THOSE AREAS
ARE OR IS IT UP TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S
WEED COMMUNITY FOCUSED. OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY TO IDENTIFY THE
ISSUES AND THEN. APPLY TO THE
STATE IN A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO GET
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE
THE HEAT. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS. IF THAT IS IF I IF
I AM CORRECT IN THAT WHAT. WHAT
IS THE MECHANISM TO MAKE SURE
THAT- BECAUSE WHAT I THINK WHAT
WE FIND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AS
WE PROVIDE THESE GRANT FUNDING
CONSERVE OUR- POOREST AND MOST
AT RISK COMMUNITIES DON'T APPLY
FOR THEM. IS OFTENTIMES THEY
DON'T HAVE THE STAFF POWER OR-
OR SOMETIMES EVEN POLITICS GET
AWAY ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE THINK IS
REALLY WHAT PEOPLE THINK. IS
NOT REAL- AND THEN WE END UP
WITH. THE POOREST COMMUNITIES
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET ACCESS.
TO THE PLANS. THE VERY GOOD
INTENTIONS WE HAVE. TO IMPROVE
LIVES YOU DRESSED OUT OVER.
THIS BILL- WILL THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH WILL ALSO
COORDINATE THE STATE'S EFFORTS
RIGHT- THAT DEAL WITH EXTREME
HEAT. I AGREE WITH YOU THAT A
LOT OF TIMES WE CREATE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAMS BUT
THEN. ARE MOST. IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES DON'T APPLY BECAUSE
OF MAYBE HUMAN RESOURCES RIDER-
THEY'RE NOT AS COMPETITIVE AND-
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT FOR A
LONG TIME YOU KNOW IT'S
SOMETIMES THAT HAS HAPPENED IN
MY DISTRICT- AND I THINK.
YOU'RE RIGHT AND I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT
THAT IS NOT THE CASE IN THIS
PROGRAM AND I'M YOU KNOW
DEFINITELY DEDICATED TO THAT.
IT AND THEY'LL BE A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE REAR TO BE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY WHAT COMMUNITIES
ARE ACTUALLY USING IT- AND WHAT
THEY ARE. GONNA WE GONNA BE
ABLE TO MEASURE ANY KIND OF
HEAT REDUCTION OR THE IMPACTS
AND I'M HOPING THAT THE THIS
PROGRAM WILL BE THEN
COORDINATED WITH LIKE AN URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM YEAH AND TO
OUR IS THERE GONNA BE SOME KIND
OF A ONE APPLICATION WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET PEOPLE EVERYTHING.
THAT THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD
BE COORDINATED- TOGETHER OR A
CONNECTED TOGETHER I GUESS THIS
IS DEFINITELY THE BEGINNING OF
COORDINATING THESE ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND EFFORTS
THAT THE STATE RUNS TOWARDS
REDUCING HEAT- RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE.
IT IS NOT ONLY FOR URBAN AREAS-
INTO THESE THOSE ARE GREAT
POINTS THAT YOU'RE MAKING AN I
DEFINITELY AGREE WITH YOU- AND
THAT'S MY INTENTION OF THAT
THIS PROGRAM WILL COORDINATE
THAT. AND ALSO BOB DO THE
OUTREACH YOU KNOW PART OF- SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
IN THIS GRANT PROGRAM ARE ALSO
PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS
AROUND HE NOT JUST TECHNOLOGIES
OR LIKE URBAN GREENING- AND SO
IT IS UP TO THE LOCAL. ENTITIES
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS ON WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE. BUT I WANT THE
STATE TO ALSO- YOU KNOW PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE AND EXAMPLES OF WHAT
CAN BE DONE AND THAT'S WHY WE
LISTED SOME OF THESE. PROGRAMS
ARE TECHNOLOGIES IN THIS BILL
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED- IN A LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE COOL PAVEMENTS AS
US SOMEONE MENTIONED IN THE
TESTIMONY. IT IS NOT REQUIRED
BUT IT IT'S A WAY TO. UP TO LET
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS KNOW THAT
THIS IS ONE AREA THAT THEY CAN
FOCUS ON. IF THEY'RE NOT AWARE
OF THAT TECHNOLOGY OKAY. SO I
GET TO DO. THE ONE THING I JUST
ALWAYS TRIED TO RESIST IS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD SHE
COULDN'T CREATE ANOTHER SILO
THAT'S THAT'S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO APPLY TO INDIVIDUALLY.
PERSON BEING ABLE TO SAY HERE'S
OUR PROBLEM WHAT DO WE WHAT WE
QUALIFY FOR- AND THEN THIS IS
NOT YOUR ISSUE BUT I THINK IN
ALL OF OUR BILLS GOING FORWARD
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD AND- TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FROM THE STATE. ON THAT ACTUAL
GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS. WHEN
YOU KNOW WHEN THIS PROGRAM IS
CREATED THERE WILL BE. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
COMMENT ON WHO SHOULD APPLY AND
HOW AND SO THAT'S BUILT INTO
THIS. PROGRAM AND I WOULD JUST
ADD A COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ALSO
DO AUTHORIZED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- BOTH FINANCIAL AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES AND THEN THE
REPORT JUST TO BE CLEAR IS IT
IT'S NOT AN ANNUAL REPORT
THERE'S A ONE TIME IN JULY
TWENTY THREE. BUT THE ACTIONS
THAT THEY'RE ANALYZING
INCLUDING ASSESSMENT OF ALL
STATE PROGRAMS- SO THAT'S ON
PAGE SEVEN EIGHT IF THAT- YES
SIR JUST TO WATCH THAT
INCLUDING UNMET GAPS POTENTIAL
GAPS- IN THE STATE'S APPROACH-
BUT I AGREE THAT EQUITY. REALLY
NEEDS TO ALSO BE A DRIVING
FORCE HERE AND I KNOW THAT'S
THE HEART OF YOUR COMMUNITY TOO
SO- I THINK IT'S AND WE'RE
GOING TO SEE A BILL A LITTLE
LATER TODAY AND BILLS IN THE
NEXT TO ME HEARING IS A LOT OF
OVERLAPPING WORK GOING ON IN
THE ADAPTATION OF RESILIENCY
SPACE SO THE IDEA OF COHESION
HEARING YOUR CROSS REFERENCE TO
THE OTHER PROCESS HE'S I THINK
IS ALSO VERY IMPORTANT. TO
SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA THERE'S
A STATE WIDE PLAN IN THIS SORT
OF ASSIST WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEN THERE'S GOING
TO BE GRANDSON URBAN GREENING
BUT AGREED GETTING ALL THAT TO
WORK ONE FRONT DOOR WILL BE
REALLY IMPORTANT I KNOW CENTER
GROVE HAD A COMMENT AND THEN
SENATOR JONES. SAWYER GROWTH.
THANK YOU MISTER. SO I THINK
ROSHI BUYER EXPERIENCES IN LIFE
AND OBVIOUSLY KERN COUNTY HAS
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES THAN LA-
THE COASTAL AREA AND- BEING A
BUSINESS OWNER IN WHAT I CALL
THE REAL WORLD. WE ALWAYS TRY
TO DETERMINE WHAT THE ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS IS LIKE WHAT'S
THE ROOT CAUSE FOR EXPENSES TO
GO UP FOR WHAT'S THE ROOT CAUSE
FOR THE INJURY TO TAKE PLACE.
AND THEN IF YOU CAN ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSE THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE A THE CONTINUOUS
BANDAID OR A FIX IT ON ON
WHATEVER THE ISSUE IS. SO FIRST
OF ALL TO SAY THAT I DO BELIEVE
IT'S FILLED ENERGY POLICIES IN
THE STATE M. BECAUSE THAT
BECAUSE- ELECTRICITY RATES TO
GO SO HIGH YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIANS IF YOU LOOK AT IT
I THINK IT'S TWENTY TWO CENTS.
IT'S ONE OF THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION'S IF NOT THE HIGHEST IN
THE NATION'S SO WHEN YOU LIVE
IN AN AREA IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY LIKE MYSELF FOR- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON. AND
WE'RE DIFFERENT THAN THE
CHAIRMAN AND HERE BECAUSE WE
CAN'T JUST OPEN A WINDOW AT
NIGHT AND- HAVE YOUR BREEZE
BLOW THROUGH AT OUR HOUSE GETS
CALLED OFF. PARDON ME. OKAY M.
SO M. I JUST THINK THAT- IF
ELECTRICITY RATES WEREN'T SO
BAD AND WE HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST- YOU KNOW POOR
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS
FARMWORKERS PREDOMINATELY
LATINO POPULATION IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT- YOU KNOW
CAN'T AFFORD AN EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLAR A MONTH UTILITY BILL OR
SEVEN HUNDRED OR MONTH UTILITY
BILL SO- I THINK THE ROOT CAUSE
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND THE
COST IS THE COST OF UTILITIES
BUT IN THE MEANTIME. I THINK
THAT- YOUR BILL DOES DO SOME
GOOD RIGHT FOR THE TO THE GRANT
PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE PEOPLE TO
APPLY FOR THEM SO THAT- YOU
KNOW IF COUNTIES OR CITIES
WANTED TO PUT TOGETHER SOME
STUFF IT WOULD BE- YOU TO BE
BENEFICIAL ESPECIALLY FOR THE
AREAS THAT WE CAN APPLY FOR THE
GRANT FROM PROGRAMS THAT YOU
HAVE IN THE BILL- I APPRECIATE
YOU CLARIFYING MR SIEVERS-
CONCERN. OVER AT DID YOU KNOW
PAVE AN ISSUE. BECAUSE AGAIN IN
THIS BUILDING WE TEND TO LOOK
AT THINGS FROM A TEN THOUSAND
FOOT VIEW. AND WE THINK THAT.
IF WE DO THIS IT WILL FIX THIS
BUT WHEN IT'S IN THE REAL
WORLD. N. LIKE MR SIEVERS
ASCRIBE YOU KNOW THE REFLECTION
OF THE PAVEMENT COULD CAUSE THE
BUILDINGS. TO BE- THE HARDER TO
COOL IN THE SUMMER TIMES- EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A GOOD CAUSE TO
HAVE LOWER HEATED AND- THAT
PAVEMENT. SO M. G. ALL THAT TO
SAY. THAT I LIKE YOUR BILL AM I
DO I'M GONNA SUPPORT IT AND I
DO WANT TO JUST ASK ONE
QUESTION I DIDN'T SEE A FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE GRANT. I GUESS
SAM WE CURRENTLY- SUBMITTED A
BUDGET REQUEST OKAY FOR THIS SO
IT IS ON UP UPON APPROPRIATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE OKAY CAN YOU
TELL WHAT THE AMOUNT IS. WHAT
THE REQUEST WITH. YOU I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU OF ANY GREAT THE
GUY I'M JUST CURIOUS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T SEE IT- SO ANYWAYS BUT I
APPRECIATE YOU LETTING. ME TO
MAKE MY COMMENTS OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
YEAH. IN THIS BEFORE. THANKS
AND GROWTH- CENTER JONES THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- JUST REAL
QUICK ON THE MOTION ON THIS.
DOES IT. IS IT DAHLE REFERRED
WHERE DOES IT GO FROM HERE.
IT'S GOING TO- EQ. AFTER ALL
OKAY AND THEN APPROACH. THE
MEASURE YES YES THE COURSE I
HAD THE SAME CONCERNS AS CENTER
GROVE ON THE FUNDING SO
APPRECIATE IF YOU CAN GET BACK
TO ALL OF US ON THAT I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT QUESTION- AND
THEN BUT REGARDING THE PAVEMENT
**** ASPHALT PAVING
ASSOCIATION. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THEY'RE ASKING FOR PRETTY
SIMPLE. AMENDMENT- K. USE ARE
YOU WILLING TO TAKE THAT A
MEMBER OR IF NOT WHY NOT ARE
YOU CAN YOU TALK TO A LITTLE
BIT. YOU KNOW THIS BILL IS
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL WE'RE NOT
PRESCRIBING COOL PAVEMENTS TO
ALL LOCAL ENTITIES RIGHT IT IS
UP TO THE NEEDS. OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS- AND I'M I'M NOT
WILLING TO REMOVE THAT AS AN
OPTION. FOR A LOCAL ENTITY TO
MAKE ON THEIR OWN DEPENDING ON
THEIR NEEDS OKAY SO IT AT MY
UNDERSTANDING THEN. IS IT'S
OPTIONAL. IT IS OKAY GOT IT
OKAY WE LISTED SEVERAL- THINGS
THAT. THE PROGRAM CAN FIND
GREAT IN. IN THIS BILL BUT IT
EVERY LOCAL ENTITY WILL MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES
THANK YOU. PICTURE JONES AND I
WOULD JUST ADD LASTLY THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT ALSO SAYS
TO AVOID MALAH ADAPTATION SIR
IS IT AS A GENERAL ISSUE SO
WHAT THE OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENT
OF CONCERN THAT. SOMEHOW COOL
PAVEMENT PROJECT WOULD HAVE AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE I THINK
WE DEALT WITH AND- THE NEW.
YOU'RE A BIN MAN SAW AND- PAGE
DATA THE ANALYSIS THERE SO-
ROBUST DISCUSSION APPRECIATED
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE HELLO ASK
YOU TO CLOSE SURE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS DISCUSSION AND
ALL OF THE COMMENTS. AND
CONCERNS I THINK IT SHOWS THAT
WE ARE ALL INTERESTED. IN
FOCUSING CALIFORNIA AND OUR
STATE'S EFFORTS ON EXTREME HEAT
AND DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE- I
DID GET. THE NUMBER AND WE IN
TERMS OF THE AMOUNT THAT WE
SUBMITTED WE SUBMITTED FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR THIS
PROGRAM- THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU- I DON'T KNOW
DO AYE THE MOTION FROM ANY
MEMBER SEVEN ENTERTAINMENT.
MOTION FOR CENTER EGGMAN- THE
MOTION IS A TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FINALLY TO MEET
AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY STERN.
STERN ALL RIGHT JONES JONES HI
ALAN. EGGMAN HI EGGMAN ALL
RIGHT GROWTH GROUP I HERTZBERG
HUESO. LAYERED HI LITTERED ALL
RIGHT LEóN. OKAY MEASURES FIVE
VOTING WILL EVEN ON CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FROM ****
CEREMONY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. CHAIR OF A AND R.
EMERITUS. IN A LETTER TO BEG
YES OKAY- WELCOME I THINK YOU
HAVE ONE MEASURE YES ONE
MEASURE FILE ITEM NINE EIGHTY
SIX FORTY TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU AND
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL- WE WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AT THE TOP
OF PAGE EIGHT DEAD AGD TO RISK
MODEL ADVISOR GROUP. I WANT TO-
ALSO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR EFFORTS TO INCREASE HOME
HARDENING AND THAT'S BEEN A
MISSION OF YEARS AND SOMETHING
THAT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SO
THANK YOU- SB SIX FORTY TWO IS
AN OMNIBUS FIRE PREVENTION BILL
THAT MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
SUPPORT CULTURAL A PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND PROTECT COMMUNITIES
FROM WILDFIRE. ON JANUARY
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
GOVERNOR'S FORCE MANAGEMENT
TASK FORCE THE M. F. T. F.
RELEASED A COMPREHENSIVE ACTION
PLAN TO REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK
PREVENTABLE COMMUNITIES AND
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF FORESTS
AND WILDLANDS. SB SIX FORTY TWO
WILL ASSIST IN IMPLEMENTING
PORTIONS OF THAT PLAN. THE
RECENT CREEK FIRE WHICH BURNED
A THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND ACRES PROVIDES AN
EXAMPLE OF THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
PRESCRIBED BURNS. THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON PROPERTY IN
SHAVER LAKE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
IMPACT TO COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCE SUBSTANTIALLY LESS
DAMAGE. ON AND NEAR THE
PROPERTY. SB SIX FORTY TWO
WOULD INCREASE THE PACE AND
SCALE.PRESCRIBING FIRE AND
TAKES IMPORTANT STEPS TO
RESTORE CULTURAL BURNING IN
CALIFORNIA. BY IMPROVING
PRESCRIBED FIRE TRAINING
PERMITTING AND THROUGH THE
CREATION OF A CULTURAL BURDEN.
LIAISON AT CALIFORNIA. SB SIX
FORTY TWO ALSO REQUIRES CAL
FIRE WITH AN ADVISORY GROUP TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
UNDERSTAND AND MODEL WILDFIRE
RISK. FOR COMMUNITY IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD AREAS THROUGH THE
INPUT OF MITIGATING FACTORS. AT
WITH TO POT WITH CLIMATE
CHANGING AND WITH DROUGHT SOME
COMMUNITIES MAY NOT RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS THAT THE RISK HAS
GONE UP SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE SIXTY ON TOP
OF THAT TO GIVE COMMUNITIES.
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED.
WE HAVE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT BY PHONE LIVE
FORSBERG FROM THE NATURAL
CONSERVANCY START. FROM THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY. AND ALISON
JULIE FROM THE WATERSHED CENTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- MODERATOR WOULD YOU
CALL ON OUR FIRST WITNESS IF
MISS FORSBERG'S ONLINE. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME A CLIPBOARD BURKE AND I'M
UTILITY TRACTOR POLICY THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY SIX FORTY KILL.
ARMY BY FIRE PREVENTION BILL
MAKING FOUR CHANGES TOOK
FAMILY'S PRESCRIBED FIRE
CULTURAL BERNIE AND SUPPORTS
COMMITTEE WELFARE RESTRICTIONS.
IN PARTICULAR AB TWENTY TWO
WOULD INCREASE THE RISK OF FIRE
I WOULD TAKE IMPORTANT STEPS TO
RESTORE CULTURAL BURNING
CALIFORNIA BY CREATING A
CULTURAL BURNING IN FRONT OF
THE DEPARTMENT FORESTRY
PROTECTION. THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A PRESCRIBED FIRE
TRAINING CENTER IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU CONSERVANCY WORKS IN
PARTNERSHIP OFFICE CRIMEFIGHTER
TRAINING EXCHANGES WHICH BUILDS
LOCAL CAPACITY FOR FIRE
MANAGEMENT WHILE IMPLEMENTING
TREATMENT THAT SUPPORT
COMMUNITY. AND LANDSCAPE OBJECT
AT. THE EXTENT TO PROVIDE
COOPERATIVE MODEL WILL
INCORPORATE LOW VALUE THE
BUILDER KINDS OF CAPACITY IN
THE RIGHT. WE BELIEVE THE
PRESCRIBED BY A TRAINING CODE
ABC FORTY COULD UP IN BY OUR-
NEEDS. IN AND CAL THE QUAN
MARKET MODEL THE STATE. FINALLY
THE PHONE IMPART TODAY OF THE
COMMITTEE WELFARE REFLECTS.
EIGHTY SIX FORTY CAN DEVELOP A
LOT BASED ON ALL TRUMP LOOK
NEEDS. AND ABOUT. MORE THAN TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE LOW
WITHIN VERY HIGH SEVERITY FIRES.
OUT HELLO THE CURRENT FORM NOT
FIND. WELL MEASURES BUT MANY
ACTIVITIES AND YOUR- EIGHTY SIX
FOR YOUR REQUIRED EIGHT MODEL
ASSIST OF THEIR KRESKIN AND THE
FIRE PREVENTION THEY CAN TAKE.
WE BELIEVE AB SIX FORTY TWO
WILL ON THE HELLO HAS TO
IMPROVE WILD RESILIENCE AND
RESPECT FOR YOUR- THANK. THANK
YOU MISS FORSBERG- MISTER ALI.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ALLISON JOLLY AND I'M A FOREST
FIRE PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT THE
WATERSHED RESEARCH AND TRAINING
CENTER ACQUIRED YOUR CHIP
FOCUSED NONPROFIT AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SIX FORTY KILL I
THINK WHEN I THINK IT'S ONLY%
NUMBER THREE TEN FOR BRINGING
NATIONAL FOREST AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT.
THE WATERSHED CENTER WHERE YOU
COULD NOT TO RESOURCE MANAGERS
GOVERNMENT AGENCY LEADERSHIP
AND COMMUNITY FIRE LEADERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE
THE EIGHTY SIX FORTY TO HELP
THREE APART TRIED AN INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE TACTICALLY SHE DIRECT
THEIR ANCESTRAL HOMELAND. IN A
WAY THAT BENEFITS ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHILE PRESERVING
THE INDIGENOUS WAYS OF LIFE IN
A STATE THAT HAS HISTORICALLY
ROCKS. NEED OF PEOPLE UP THERE
RIGHT. DON'T START DO THIS NEED
QUESTIONS WERE. ESTABLISH OF A
COW FIRE CULTURAL BURNING
LIAISON OFFICER. RANG THE
DEPARTMENT ON TO VOGUE ON THE
CORE MORE IN LEADERS. ORANGE
APPS BUT NOT THE ONLY ONE
NEEDED INVESTMENT TRIBAL SELF
GOVERNANCE AND SELF
DETERMINATION ARE ALSO NEEDED.
THE BILL ALSO MOVED FROM THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL TO THE
CALIFORNIA UNIT LEVEL FOR BURN
BANS CONSIDER THE KLAMATH FALLS
THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. MOAKLEY CONDITIONS
ARE PRESCRIBED FIRE OPTIONAL
BUT UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
STATEWIDE BURN BANS THE
CONTROLLED BURN COULD NOT MOVE
FORWARD. THE NEXT YEAR THE SAME
AREA EXPERIENCED A WILDFIRE
THAT TO FLY HOME IN CRITICAL
HABITAT. A WIDE REMAINDER TO
COURT YOUR TOPPER LOCAL NEON
INCOME AT THEIR COST. EIGHTY
SIX FORTY TWO CENTER MEDIATE
THAT BY EMPOWERING UNITS TO
ISSUE ONE PARTLY NOT ISSUED
BURN BAN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
I APPRECIATE IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN PLEADING FELL. IN WITH
THE PORT EIGHTY SIX FORTY TWO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH- ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON HAND TO
TESTIFIED SUPPORT SEEING ON
HERE OR IN A REMOTE ROOMS. THAT
WILL TURN TO THE LINES OPERATOR
CAN YOU CHECK IF WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF.
AB SIX FORTY TWO. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FORTY TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
THIS IS BOB RAYMER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO GIVE US STRONG SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND THE BUILDING
OWNERS AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY ONE. MISTER JERRY
MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WORK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PINE.
SEVENTY ONE. THE MORNING AFTER
HEARING SENATORS WITH NOEL
KRAMER'S WITH PLANES YOU
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY. MARGARINE MEMBERS
BRIAN SHOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR. NINE
FORTY THREE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WELL GROWER
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
WORK FOR EIGHTY SIX FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER. NEXT. ONE
SIXTY FIVE. ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
VERY GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIX FORTY KILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LEVINE SEVENTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRED
SENATORS MARK FENSTER MAKER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
SCORED EIGHTY SIX FORTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
SEVEN. DOCUMENTARY MEMBERS
NATALIE NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IS
THE RED WITH WEAKENED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
OKAY- LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION
AND ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANY REMOTELY.
SEEING NONE ANY ON THE LINES IT
WAS TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. AND TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX FORTY TWO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
GOING QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
OKAY A SENIOR OPPOSITION.
SEIGNER POSITION- JUST TO
CLARIFY AS A MEMBER YOU ARE
TAKING SECOND COUNTY AMENDMENTS
YES OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
LEAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS YES CENTER LAYERED AND
THEN COME TO SENATOR GRAHAM.
THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR. FOR BRINGING THE BILL AND-
JUST LAST FRIDAY ARE YOUR
COLLEAGUES ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE AND I VISITED THE C. C.
U. FIRES CAR. AND THERE'S ONE
PARTICULAR. EIGHTY EIGHT
HUNDRED ACRE LAND WITH THE LAND
CONSERVATION EASEMENT ON IT OR
THEY DID A PRESCRIBED FIRE ONE
SIDE IT WAS THE ONLY HOMES THAT
WERE SAVED IN THE AREA OF THAT
FIRE WERE PROTECTED BY THAT ONE
PARTICULAR. PRESCRIBED BURN
AND- THE HISTORIC- TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE AREA
ARE WORKING WITH THEM ABOUT THE
ARCHAEOLOGICAL RESOURCES AND
UNDERSTANDING PRESCRIBED FIRE
AND IT IS A NATURAL FIT WITH
YOUR WITH YOUR BILL. AND CENTER
EGGMAN WILL ROLLER I SAT MY- A
LATE IS SHAMELESS- A PLUG FOR
THE FACT THAT WE RESTORED A YOU
SEE AG COOPERATIVE EXTENSION IN
THE BUDGET YESTERDAY AND ADDED
TO ACROSS THE STATE AND YOU
HAVE CALLED THEM OUT FOR DOING
EDUCATION AND- HOPEFULLY THEY
WILL HAVE MORE RESOURCES TO DO
THAT GIVEN THE BUDGET THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE. ADOPTED
IN TWO I HAVE A BILL THAT IS
NOT REFERENCED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT MOVING THIS YEAR THAT
TAKES THE ACTION PLAN OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY PUTS
IT OVER FIVE YEARS- TO SORT OF
PLAN FOR EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
pDOING BUT TO SIGNIFICANT PIECE
IN RELATION TO YOUR BILL. IS
THAT IT ACTUALLY TRACKS AND HAS
A TRANSPARENT WAY. TO DETERMINE
WHAT IS DONE EVERY YEAR GETS
THE GOALS ON PRESCRIBED FIRE
FEW MANAGEMENT FORCE MANAGEMENT
AND OTHER PRACTICES AND SO. IF
AND WHEN THIS BILL PASSES THERE
WILL BE A WIDE TRACK. OF
WHETHER OR NOT IT ACHIEVES WHAT
THE DESIRED GOALS OR A NEW WAY
TO TRACK HOW MUCH THE ACREAGE
ACTUALLY IS THAT IS EXPERIENCED
BY IT. SO I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT BILL I SEE YOU A BROAD
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION INTO
A HOBBY HAPPY TO MOVE IT WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD THANK YOU A
CENTER GROVE. AND THEN CENTER
EGGMAN S. THANK YOU MISTER.
IT'S A EATING THE CREEK FIRE.
SINCE THE NINETEEN FIFTIES MY
FAMILY HAS CAMPED UP THERE
EVERY YEAR AT ABOVE SHAVER LAKE
AT HUNTINGTON LAKE. IN THE
CREEK FIRE CAME THROUGH IS IT
WAS PRETTY DEVASTATING NOT ONLY
FOR. THAT BEAUTIFUL AREA UP
THERE IN THIS YEAR FOR NATIONAL
FOREST BUT FOR WILDLIFE- FOR
WILDLIFE FOR THE HORSES IN THE
CATTLE THE- YOU KNOW. THERE'S A
LOT OF RANCHERS INCLUDING
ARRANGING FAMILIES THAT AT
LEAST WITH THE FOR SERVICE AND
JUST TO GET IN AND GET THEIR
CATTLE OUT AND- YOU KNOW A
GROUP OF PEOPLE LEFT KERN
COUNTY AND WENT UP THERE TO
HELP- ONE. PARTICULAR FLAG
RANCHER THAT IS WELL KNOWN AND-
YOU KNOW. THEY WERE GETTING
CATTLE OUT WITH BURNED HIS LIKE
YOU KNOW WE'RE ANIMALS GO RIGHT
WHEN THAT HAPPENS. AND I'VE
OFTEN ADVOCATED FOR UNIFICATION
MANAGEMENT AND PRESCRIBED BURNS
THINGS LIKE THAT BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW CAMPING UP THERE FOR YOU
KNOW SINCE I WAS A KID- AND MY
MOM AND DAD BEFORE THAT- YOU
KNOW EAST BILL TO GO TO OUR
CAMPSITE A WALK DIRECTLY TO THE
LAKE. AND NOW YOU CAN'T DO THAT
M. YOU HAVE TO WALK ALL THE WAY
AROUND BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
VEGETATION ON THE GROUND- AND
SMALL TREES THAT YOU CAN'T GET
TO THE LAKE. AND I THINK THAT
JUST- PER VOIGTS KINDLING AT
YOU KNOW FUEL FOR THESE FIRES
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY WE HAD
SUCH A DEVASTATING LOSS WITH
THE CREEK FIRE. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL AND THANK
YOU M. FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SCHERING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL
AND I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
EVERY. TOOL IN OUR TOOLBOX AND
I THINK PRESCRIBERS HAVE NOT
BEEN USED AS MUCH AS WE KNOW
HISTORICALLY IT'S- IT IS A WAY
TO KEEP WORKFORCE CLEAN- I.
ALSO HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
IN THE AREA WHERE THE CREEK
FIRE OCCURRED AND WE LOST MY
DAD SOLD OFF THE GRID CABIN.
AND CHOSE NOT TO EVEN THINK
ABOUT REBUILDING AS A BURN TO
THE GROUND JUST BECAUSE THE
DEVASTATION IS SO MASSIVE THAT.
I DON'T THINK IN MY LIFETIME
THAT AREA. WE'RE WEEK WHERE WE
HIKED AND FISHED WELL WE'LL BE
BACK. IN ANY WAY THAT I CAN
ENJOY IT. SO I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND I HOPE
THAT WHEN THE PLANS ARE
DEVELOPED ACTUALLY ENCOMPASS- I
MEAN REALLY LOOK AT THE AMOUNT
OF SPACE THAT NEEDS TO BE.
CUPBOARD AND ENTREATED. AND
THAT IT IS ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT LARGER. AREAS I THINK
SOMETIMES WE DO IN SMALL PATCH
AREAS WHICH ISN'T AS EFFECTIVE
SO. HOPEFULLY WILL MOVE TOWARDS
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE PLAN. THAT
WILL INCLUDE ALL ALL PROPERTY
OWNERS AS IT GOES FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE DO
HAVE A PROMOTION FROM CENTER
LAYERED I'LL JUST SAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP. IN
THIS AREA YOU'VE BEEN AT THIS
FOR A WHILE. WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT THAT CRITICAL MODEL
COMPONENT OF YOUR LEGISLATION
WHICH SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN LAW
YEARS AGO- AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR PERSISTENCE ON THAT
ESPECIALLY THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND
SORT OF THAT ROLE OF MODELING
RISK- MAYBE THEY'LL BEAT US TO
TH PUNCH HERE AND- GET MOVING.
BUT I APPRECIATE THESE BILLS
MOVING TO MAKE SURE THAT
HAPPENS THE ONE THING I WANTED
TO NOTE- YOU KNOW I THINK THIS
IS ALSO. AN IMPORTANT TRUST
BUILDING EXERCISE IN THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS HE'S
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET PEOPLE MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT. THIS CAN
DO- BUT IT DOES NOT. EXPRESSLY
DOES NOT CONTRAVENE ANYTHING IN
EXISTING LAW THE WAY THE
COMMITTEE IS READY TO. TO
EXACERBATE ANY TYPE CONVERSION
WE KNOW THAT AFTER SOME FIRES-
INVASIVES COME BACK IN SO. IN
AREAS. WHERE THERE ARE AT THE
CHAPARRAL AND COASTAL SAGE
SCRUB. IF YOU PRESCRIBED FIRE
THAT AND THEN IT COMES BACK AS
MUSTARD WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED
AND WE'LL SEE IS ALL THE
CHAPARRAL IS GONE AND NOW WE
HAVE TEN FOOT HIGH COMBUSTIBLE
INVASIVE GRASSES. AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES- THE BILL- SORT OF
NAVIGATES THROUGH THAT THAT
COMPLEXITY I THINK ASTUTELY SO
I APPRECIATE THAT. IT'S NOT A
SORT OF ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH BUT YOU ARE BUILDING
TRUST. AND PUSHING HIS PRACTICE
FOR WHERE WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE- SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION- DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE.
THE ONLY THING THAT I'LL ADD IS
THAT. ALSO PART OF THE MODELING
BESIDES REDUCING RISK IS TO
REWARD COMMUNITIES THAT THAT
ACTUALLY DO A LOT OF
REMEDIATION AND DO A LOT OF
WORK. AND THAT POSSIBLY
INSURANCE COMPANIES REALIZING
THAT THEY HAVE REDUCED THE RISK
AND REWARDING THEM WITH LOWER
INSURANCE RATES IS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WOULD THIS COULD
HELP FOSTER AND- I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT YOU ALL MADE IN THE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH- THE MOTION IS. TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION- SHE
CANCELED WHICH PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB SIX TWO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS STERN.
HI EARN ALL RIGHT JONES. ALAN
ACT ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN.
EGGMAN RA GROOVE. GROOVE HI
HERTZBERG. HUESO LAYERED HI
LEARN ARE ALONE. LIMóN ALL
RIGHT. VERY GOOD THANK YOU WILL
LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOU SEE. RIGHT ON
CUE SAID NUMBER GABRIEL YOU'RE
WITH US. FILE ITEM TWELVE
MEMBERS. THE. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU IN PLACE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. WHICH ONE POWER STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK SO THAT
STATE AGENCIES CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY. TO ADDRESS OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS AND WE'RE
FEELING THE IMPACTS OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
AROUND THE WORLD. LAST SUMMER
IN OUR DISTRICT CENTER WAS A
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DEGREES IN
WOODLAND HILLS THE HIGHEST
TEMPERATURE EVER RECORDED IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WAS A
HUNDRED SIXTEEN DEGREES IN
CANADA. A FEW DAYS AGO WE'VE
GOT RECORD BREAKING FLOODS IN
DETROIT AND EXPLOSIVE WILDFIRES
RISING SEA LEVELS ALL OF THE
SIGNS THAT ARE COMMON REALITY-
CRISIS IS HERE AND AN URGENT
CALL TO ACTION. AND WHILE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ENACTED
FRAMEWORKS AND ENDORSE VARIOUS
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS. WE
STILL LACK GOVERNANCE
PARTICIPATION AND METRICS ON
CRITICAL PARTY ACTIONS AND
TIMELINES TO ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION GOALS AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL. IN THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THAT GAP OF BY
ASKING THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL TO DEVELOP AND
COORDINATE A STRATEGIC RESULT
RESILIENCY FRAMEWORK. THAT WILL
OUT TIMETABLES AND METRICS TO
MEASURE PROGRESS IN ACHIEVING
THAT FRAMEWORK AND FACILITATE
TIMELY CONCRETE ACTION. AND
ALSO TO ELEVATE EQUITY AS A AS
A CONSIDERATION BY IDENTIFYING.
AND PROVIDING SPECIAL
PROTECTIONS FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND I WANT
TO. THANK THE CHAIR. AND HIS
THEIR COMMITTEE STAFFER THE
HARD WORK IN THE FOUGHT FOR
ASSISTANCE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU-
AND SENATOR ALLEN. NOW BASED ON
THE COMMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AS WE HOPE TO MOVE
FORWARD ON TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE VERY THOUGHTFUL CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED. IN TESTIFYING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ARE READ OUT US ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
ANTI AND- WINE INTO ON BEHALF
OF CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT. SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- LET'S TURN YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES THEN- MISTER ADAMS
ARE YOU ON THE LINE IF SO YOU
MAY PROCEED. BOARDING CHAIR
MEMBERS READ OUT AS ON BEHALF A
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
WHERE NONPROFIT LOCATED IN THE-
L. A. COUNTY REGION DEDICATED
TO BREAKING DOWN BARRIERS TO
NATURE FOR OUR VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES. IN MANY WAYS YOU
COULD SAY WE'RE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CLEARLY SEE. THE IMPACTS TO
PEOPLE IMPACTS THE NATURE INTO
OUR COMMUNITY. THERE'S MUCH TO
DO AND THAT MUCH NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO PREPARE FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION. SOME IS ALREADY
BEEN DONE AND SENATOR LIAR GO
THROUGH THE SAFEGUARDING PLAN-
BUT OTHER WORK STILL NEEDS TO
BE DONE AS YOU HEARD EARLIER
TODAY I HEARD SENATOR EGGMAN
MENTION I NEED TO THINK ABOUT
MEASURING COORDINATING. AND HOW
TO HAVE STATE POLICY THEY
INTERACT WITH THE REGION. WORD
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR TODAY BECAUSE IT
DOES PROVIDE AN OVERARCHING
POLICY. IT HELPS CLARIFY
GOVERNANCE AND MANAGEMENT. IT
SPECIFICALLY SAYS WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY HAVE GOALS AND METRICS
WHAT WE YAKKING TO AND HOW ARE
WE MAKING SURE ALL STATE
AGENCIES ARE GROWING IN THE
SAME DIRECTION. CLEARLY WE WANT
TO PUT EQUITY AT THE FRONT OF
THAT POLICY WE THINK AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY QUARTERBACK.
AND FINALLY IT SPECIFICALLY
SAYS THAT WHAT THE STATE DOES
AND HOW THE STATE THINKS ABOUT
CLIMATE ADAPTATION. NO MATTER
WHAT WE SAY WE NEED TO BE
WORKING WITH ON THE VARIOUS
REGIONS AND MAKE SURE THERE'S
ULTIMATE PRETTY PRETTY
COORDINATION GOING ON THERE.
FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS
WARRANT SUPPORT TODAY. AND
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF THE
CHAIR. AND- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR IS THE NEXT WITNESS A-
YES WHEN. WELCOME TO THE
MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DIANA WINE AND I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CHAPTER OF THE CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT MISSION IS TO CATALYZE
A GLOBAL SOLUTION TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS BY MAKING URGENT
ACTION A NECESSITY ACROSS EVERY
SECTOR OF SOCIETY TODAY I'M
HONORED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL.
THE BILL WILL REQUIRE STATE
AGENCIES TO COLLABORATIVELY
ENGAGE WITH REGIONAL AND LOCAL
ENTITIES AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO DEVELOP AND
COORDINATE STRATEGIC RESILIENCY
FRAMEWORK THAT WOULD ADDRESS
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.-CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
CLIMATE CHALLENGE REGIONS IN
NORTH AMERICA IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGION SPECIFICALLY IT
IS EXPECTED TO WARM FOUR TO
FIVE DEGREES BY MID CENTURY.
AND THE YEARLY NUMBER OF DAYS
OVER NINETY FIVE DEGREES IS
PROJECTED TO ALMOST QUADRUPLE
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
CLIMATE SCIENTISTS HAVE
PREDICTED THAT THE SEA LEVEL
WILL RISE ALONG THE CALIFORNIA
COAST FIVE TO TWENTY FOUR
INCHES. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY FIFTY. TIED TO THE
STORM SURGE CAN CAUSE COASTAL
FLOODING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY WHEN BIG WAVES
STORMS OCCUR AT HIGH TIDE. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALSO SUFFERS
FROM SOME OF THE WORST AIR
POLLUTION IN THE COUNTRY WHICH
IS THE PROBLEM WORSENED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. QATAR
TEMPERATURES SPEED UP CHEMICAL
REACTIONS THAT CREATE GROUND
LEVEL OZONE WHICH IS THE MAIN
COMPONENT OF SMOG. GROUND LEVEL
OZONE IS LINKED TO ASTHMA
BRONCHITIS HEART ATTACKS AND
PREMATURE DEATH. IT IS CRITICAL
THAT THE STATE TAKE ACTION ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMAN
GABRIEL WILL CREATE COORDINATED
GOVERNMENTAL ACTIONS ON
CRITICAL PRIORITY ACTIONS. AND
TIMELINES TO ACHIEVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR
GUESTS VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU
MISS ONE AND- OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE LEGISLATION I DON'T SEE
ANY HERE IN THE ROOM OR ANY IN
OUR REMOTE HEARING ROOMS. SO WE
WILL TURN TO THE LINES. ARE
PRETTY WANNA OPEN LINES FOR AND
THIS IS JUST NAME AFFILIATION
AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
SEVENTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MORNING CAME IN CONTACT WITH
THE BALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
NATALIE MAC WILL BE HALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION MADONSELA RICH NOT
LOOKING FACE DISTRICTS LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD MANTRA THE
MANTRA SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
PART OF AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN. HELLO OUR
PARTY AND ALL THAT HAPPENED
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PINE SEVENTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS KATHY SHAFFER
LEGISLATIVE COORDINATOR FOR SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TESTIFIED
TAXED. WE ARE LOW NELSON COULD
THIS TIME STRUCTURE OKAY- WE
WILL TURN INTO OUR ANY IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANY IN THE ROOM. OR REMOTE
HEARING ROOMS- YOUR TURN TO THE
LINE'S OPERATOR AND JUST SEE IF
WE HAVE ANYONE IN Q. ONE
OPPOSITION WE'VE NOT LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS. WE HAVE THE LOWER
LISTED OPPOSITION FOR THEIR
RIGHT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OKAY. OF THE TELEPHONE LINES IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
WELL KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER OKAY VERY GOOD WILL
BRING IT BACK- COME IN BURSTS
ORDER THEN MR LAYERED AND THEN
THE SECOND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THE END TO THE
AUTHOR I REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
DIRECTION IN THIS AND- IT WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE SEARCH. THE
COR IS SO AND IS. A WAS A
MEMBER OF THE ST GROWTH COUNCIL
FOR EIGHT YEARS SO I GUESS WHAT
YOU'RE TO DO A OF. IN THE ONE
IS- PROTON HAS A MAJOR SEA
LEVEL RISE THE NOT REFERENCED
IN THE ANNOUNCES THAT ACTUALLY.
UP A PROCESS. AND A CALL. FOR
DRESSINGS LEVEL RISE AND I
HEARD THE WITNESSES MENTIONED
IT AND- HOW WHAT STEPS WILL
YOU. TAKE TO MAKE SURE THAT. IF
HER BILL WAS ENACTED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW AND THIS IS SIGNED
INTO LAW THERE'S NOT SOME
DUPLICATION HERE HOW WOULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT. YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR AND IT'S A IT'S A
ACTUAL QUESTION AND YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO BUILD ON A LOT OF THE
GOOD WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE IN
YOUR UNIT IN PREVIOUS ROLES TO
HELP TO GET US TO THIS MOMENT-
WE SEE THIS REALLY IS BEING OUT
OF IT AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
FRAMEWORK THAT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE. WORKING ON A LOT OF
ISSUE AREAS IN MORE SPECIFIC
DETAIL COMMENT AS YOU MAY KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN HAS%
ABOUT WORKING ON REGIONAL
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND
ADAPTATION SO. WE THINK IT'S
COMPLIMENTARY TO THAT AS WELL
SO WE'RE TRYING TO BE IN
CONVERSATION WITH EVERYBODY
THAT'S WORKING IN THE SPACE.
BUT WE THINK THESE EFFORTS ARE
ULTIMATELY COMPLEMENTARY AND
THAT THERE COULD BE LOTS OF
EFFORTS ON PARTICULAR THINGS.
WHETHER BE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
WHETHER B. C. LEVEL RISE
WHETHER BE OTHER ISSUES WHERE
WE CAN FOCUS ON THE POLICY AND
MORE- GRANO DETAIL. BUT ALSO
HELP TO HAVE COORDINATION AT
THE TOP LEVEL SO THAT ALL OF
THIS CAN ULTIMATELY BE MOVING
IN THE SAME DIRECTION. AND I'M
PRESENTED TO PROTECT HIS BILL
IN ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES.
I GUESS I WAS JUST LAST WEEK
AND SO I WOULD JUST SUGGEST.
THAT YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC
CONVERSATION WITH OUR STAFF. IN
CASE THERE'S A WAY. THAT YOU
NEED TO ACTUALLY SPECIFIED IN
YOUR BILL BUT THEY'RE NOT IN
CONFLICT OR OR DEAL WITH IT
ANNOYS IT'S GOOD. SECOND AND
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD IS.
THEIR NUMBER VOICE TO GO WITH
THIS WHY DID YOU CHOOSE THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL. YEAH
I'LL JUST SAY ON YOUR ON ON THE
PLAYMATE ABSOLUTELY AND WE WILL
DEFINITELY REACH OUT TO THE
PART TIME AND I THINK THAT'S A
WELL TAKEN POINT- SO IT'S SO
IT'S SO THANK YOU FOR THAT- SO.
OUR OUR ASSUMPTION ALL ALONG IS
THAT ULTIMATELY THIS WOULD BE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THAT YOU KNOW
REASONABLE MINDS COULD DISAGREE
ABOUT. SHOULD THIS BE HOUSED IN
OPR SERVICE BECAUSE THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN THE STRATEGIC ACCOUNTS AND
WE DECIDED TO. BEGIN WITH THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
BECAUSE REPRESENTATIVES. FROM
BOTH OF THOSE ENTITIES AND IS A
PLACE WHERE FOLKS CAN GET
TOGETHER- AND HOPEFULLY HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
ULTIMATELY WE THINK THAT
THAT'LL BE A CONVERSATION WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND WORKING
WITH THEM TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THIS IS ULTIMATELY SO IN MANY
WAYS THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCILS A STARTING POINT FOR
YOU AND YOU'LL SEE HOW THEY
RESPOND. CORRECT I THE ONE. ON
MY OWN TIME MISTER CHAIR THE
ONE OBSERVATION I WOULD. MAKE
IS THAT. THE SORT OF A THE ONE
HAND ON THE OTHER HAND WITH
THAT. IT ON THE ONE HAND IT'S
GREAT BECAUSE IT'S DESIGNED TO
COORDINATE ANOTHER CAT A NUMBER
OF CABINET LEVEL SECRETARIES.
SO THAT YOU GET INTO EVERY
PLACE TO ISSUE MIGHT EXIST. IN
MANAGING IT AND THERE ARE
PUBLIC APPOINTMENTS AND- AND IN
THE PAST I DON'T KNOW WHO'S
THERE NOW THE PUBLIC
APPOINTMENTS ADDRESSED. EQUITY
A IN A WAY TO MOVE THAT INTO
THE CONVERSATION. THE FLIP SIDE
OF IT IS. IS IF EVERYBODY SORT
OF HAS A LITTLE RESPONSIBILITY
NOBODY HAS THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY AND- YOU COULD.
GET A SITUATION WHERE NOBODY
SHEPHERDING IT NOBODY'S REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS AND SO. I WOULD JUST
HOPE YOU WOULD HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. IT IN A TIMELY
BASIS BECAUSE THE REAL ISSUE IS
MAKING SURE THIS HAPPENS AND
MAKING SURE THIS HAPPENS IN A
GOOD WAY ADMINISTRATIVE PLAN
SO. I'M GONNA BE HAPPY TO VOTE
FOR THIS BILL TODAY AND REALLY
SALUTE YOU. I JUST THINK YOU
STILL NEED TO WORK ON A COUPLE
OF THOSE ISSUES AND- SO THAT
THIS. DOES THE BEST IT CAN BE
AS A CONSOLE SO I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH PARTICULARLY
GIVEN YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR PRIOR
EXPERIENCE HERE IN THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU BRING TO
IT AND- YOU KNOW WE SOUGHT
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE FROM
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES AS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS IN ABOUT PASSED THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR. THEIR
THOUGHTS ALREADY ON AMENDMENTS
WERE JUST WAITING TO HEAR BACK
FROM THEM BUT I HEAR EXACTLY
WHAT. YOU'RE SAYING WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. AT THE
MOMENT THANK YOU- AT AND I
WOULD NEVER ROLL MY EYES. AT
MONEY FOR DO YOU SEE AG
EXTENSION SENATOR LAYER TO LAST
LAST POINT- AND I AM NOT AS
KNOWLEDGEABLE AS- AS THE FINE
SENATOR FORMER SECRETARY. SO
FOR ME WHO SOMEONE WHO REALLY
LIKES TO FOCUS ON OUTCOMES AND
RIGHT HAS BEEN HERE QUITE
AWHILE AND THE KEEP DOING
THINGS AND SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T
FEEL LIKE WE- FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH REAL OUTCOMES. WHY IF WE
ALREADY HAVE. MANY PEOPLE
WORKING IN THE SPACE WHY NOT
JUST MAYBE DO MORE. TO
SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA
MANDATES THAT PROGRAM IS
ALREADY EXISTING AS THE CENTER
LAYERED AND SAYS IN THE WE ONE
PERSON RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE- I
THINK. THE LAST THING ANYBODY
WANTS THAT WE'VE SEEN TO THIS
IS FINGER POINTING THIS WAY OR
THE OTHER WAY. SO WHY NOT. SIX
IMPORTANT WHAT WE ALREADY HAVE
VERSUS BEGINNING SOMETHING NEW.
YEAH IT'S A GREAT POINT SENATOR
AND I THINK THAT THE THRUST OF
THIS BILL IS TO IS TO MOVE FROM
PLAN INTO ACTION RIGHT AND THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF GOOD WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE IN THE SPACE
BUT HOW DO WE TAKE IT TO THE
NEXT STEP HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. MEASURABLE
DEMONSTRABLE OUTCOMES THAT ARE
GOING TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
FORWARD HERE- THEY WERE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WE WANT TO DO THAT IN A
WAY THAT SENSITIVE TO ALL THE
WORK THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE
HERE- GOING BACK OVER OVER A
DECADE AND BUILT ON THAT
DOESN'T RECREATE THE WELL BUT
LEVERAGES WHAT WE'VE BEEN DONE
AND REALLY YOU KNOW AT SOME
SOME SOME TEETH AND SOME HAVE
TO IT AND MOVED IT TO THE NEXT
LEVEL. SO THAT IS A THAT THAT'S
VERY MUCH THE INTENT HERE AGAIN
I THINK WE ALL BELIEVE THIS IS
IMPORTANT BURKE- AND THIS BILL
I THINK STILL HAS A LITTLE BIT
OF WORK TO BE DONE IN THE
SECOND HOUSE NOW SO- I APPLAUD
YOU BUT LET'S LET'S MAKE SURE
WE GET IT RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK
THE LAST THING WE NEED TO DO.
IS BE CREATING MORE FRAMEWORKS
AND STRATEGIES THAT THAT THAT
WOULD THAT WE NEVER ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT AND UP THAT THE
CITIZENS NEVER ACTUALLY SEE THE
BENEFIT OF. A GIFT. THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN- COMMITTEE CENTER
AROUND- ARE YOU KNOW I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR IS
ENGAGED IN THIS ISSUE AND-
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WE COULD
HAVE SUPPORTED TODAY. YOU KNOW
IT'S GONNA COME ALREADY THE
INTERNAL QUALITY COMMITTEE- AND
THERE'S SOME THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
STILL A LOT MORE WORK TO DO I
HONESTLY I GOT IT I WAS A
DECEASED YOU KNOW DIRECTLY THAT
I'M NOT SURE THE DISTANCE THAT
THE SHIFT TO THE STREET ACROSS
COUNCIL IS THE RIGHT DECISION.
I'M CERTAINLY OPEN TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION WITH YOU IS THIS
ISN'T AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
TO COME TO OUR COMMITTEE I KNOW
WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER- MARC COMMITTEE AND
DONE. BETTER RESOURCES AND YOU-
I THINK THERE'S A LT OF REALLY
GOOD STUFF IN THIS BILL THE
TRYING TO GET OUT I THINK THE
QUESTION IS. WHAT SORT OF
FRAMEWORK. AND HOW DO WE- HOW
DO WE ENSURE THIS IS REALLY
EFFECTIVE. AS WERE AS WERE
WORKING WITHIN THE BUREAUCRACY
IN IS ALL THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES AND- I THINK THERE. IS
AN ARGUMENT TO MAKE DINNER IS
REALLY. THE RIGHT PLACE FOR
THIS WORK SO- I LOOK FOR TO
THAT DISCUSSION I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY TO
KEEP THE CONVERSATION MOVING
BUT- I WILL I WILL SAY THAT
I'M- STRUGGLING WITH- WITH
WEATHER. PSPC SHOULD BE GIVEN
THE PARAMOUNT RESPONSIBILITY
YOUR BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
ENVISIONS OB BUT I DO THINK WE
SHARE THE SAME BROAD GOALS AND
LET'S FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THERE THANK YOU CENTER I
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE GOT SOME
VERY HELPFUL YOU KNOW FEEDBACK
AND GUIDANCE FROM FROM SENATOR
LEAD ON THAT AND VERY VERY OPEN
TO THAT CONVERSATION AND EAGER
TO ENGAGE IN A TERROR AND
TRYING TO WORK TO GET THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE ON
ALL THESE THINGS SO THAT WE
CAN- SO THAT WE CAN LAND IN A
GOOD PLACE AND ALL THAT BUT BUT
REALLY DO LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION IN THE TEN YEARS.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT JUST DOESN'T
BECOME A REPORT THAT SITS ON A
SHELF BUT SOMETHING THAT
ACTUALLY MOVES US TO ACTION
THAT RESULTS IN IN YOU KNOW
OUTCOMES THAT ARGUE THAT WE
pNEW REALITY WITH OUR CLIMATE
SITUATION AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
THE THRUST HERE AND WE'RE GOING
TO YOU KNOW SENATE COMMITTEE
MOVES FOR TODAY REALLY LOOK FOR
TO THAT CONVERSATION WITH YOUR
STAFF CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE STAFF HERE AND
HOPEFULLY GET TO SOMETHING WE
ALL FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT.
CENTER THERE TO WILL BRING YET
THANK YOU CENTER I THINK WE HAD
ONE MORE I CAN'T I CAN'T RESIST
A MOMENT OF LEVITY AND IT BASED
ON CENTER ALLEN'S COMMENTS AND
THAT IS HE IS THE ACRONYM NRA
AND TO A- YEAH AND WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN I WAS IN
THE I WAS TRYING TO GET JONES
AND ALL WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY- I PRIDED MYSELF ON
BEING A HIGH MINDED LEGISLATOR
THAT WOULD NEVER BE FRIVOLOUS.
AND I CAST A NO VOTE. ON THE
CHAIN FROM THE RESOURCES AGENCY
TO THAT NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY BECAUSE I DID NOT WANT
TO PUT THE NRA ENTIRE
TRANSITION WILDLIFE RIGHT IT
AND I ENDED UP BEING THE
SECRETARY OF THE NRA FOR EIGHT
YEARS BECAUSE IT PASSED OVER MY
VOTE SO POWER ADJUSTABLE FRONT
IS A- JUST THOUGHT I WOULD NOTE
THAT FOR GOING TO PRIVILEGE
RISEN Y. LOCK. I LIKE SENATOR
LAYERED YEAH EXACTLY. EQUAL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DE ON MATTER
AND SORT OF WRESTLING ALL THESE
ISSUES THAT HAVE SURFACED HERE-
AND I WOULD JUST NOTE IT TO THE
EXTENT IT'S USEFUL TO YOU ALL
WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T SORT OF
LAND EXACTLY WHAT WE WANTED
FOR. FINALLY YOU KNOW SORT OF-
SIGNATURE READY BUT I THINK
PAID SIXTY ANALYSIS TALK ABOUT
THIS THIS NOTION OF CLIMATE
READINESS THREE THINK WE'LL
HOPEFULLY ADD SOME GRANULARITY
TO WHAT THESE GOALS ARE SO
WE'RE NOT JUST PLANNING IS THIS
FAMILY MEMBER POINTED OUT JUST
ANOTHER PLAN I WORKED ON AS AN
INTERN IN LAW SCHOOL WORKED ON
THE FIRST VERSION OF THE
SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA PLAN.
BACK UNDER MY CHRISTMAS. YEAH I
KNOW AND I'M AND WE HAD BIG
IDEAS AND WE'RE TALKING A
TRILLION DOLLAR LIABILITIES AND
THEN HERE WE ARE. THE STATE'S
BURNING DOWN WE STILL HAVEN'T
ADAPTED AND HEATS HAPPENING AND
THE CROPS ARE GOING SO. WE CAN
PLAN ALL WE WANT- WE STILL I
DON'T THINK IS A STATE HAVE
FULLY RECOGNIZE THE LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT IT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE BOTH PHYSICALLY. AND
FROM A GOVERNMENT COORDINATION
PERSPECTIVE TO DEAL WITH THE
SCALE. THIS TRUE SCALE OF THIS
SO IF WE CAN START TO GET TO.
SECTORAL READY MIX AND REALLY
START TO UNDERSTAND WHAT DOES A
FIRE HARD IN. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LOOK LIKE AND HOW DO
YOU ACTUALLY DEFINE THAT- WHAT
METRICS COULD WE SET UP ON SEA
LEVEL RISE THAT FELT MEANINGFUL
SAID THE PRO TEM'S BILL COULD.
COULD SORT OF ACCELERATE THAT
EFFORT ANY HOUSE SO JUST A FLAG
THAT IS AN ISSUE ONE OF THE
FOUR ISSUES WE'RE GONNA WORK.
WITH YOU ON GOING FORWARD- IT'S
A HUGE TOPIC. BUT IT'S YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT TO BE STEPPING IN
ON AND I APPRECIATE YOU THE
REPRESENTING OUR DISTRICT SO
WELL TO AND EDUCATING EVERYONE
THAT. THESE AREN'T JUST COASTAL
SEATS ADDED THAT HUNDRED TWENTY
DEGREES KILLS- SO- THANKS FOR
TAKEN SO SERIOUSLY AND FOR
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US. WE
HAVE NO OTHER COMMENTS OFF ON
MOVED THE BILL AT THE MOTION
FIRM CENTER LAYERED. A LADY
CLOSER. YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT SENATOR I LEARN
SOMETHING EVERY TIME I COME
OVER TO THE SENATE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT- THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMENTS APPRECIATE THAT WE
ARE VERY MUCH COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT SAYS.
THAT YOU REYES ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ELEVATE EQUITY IN
THIS CONVERSATION THAT THAT IS
VERY MUCH AT THE FOREFRONT OF
PEOPLE'S MINDS AS WE DO THAT.
AN- WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR SO THE MOST IS. ON HIS. TO
PASS AB FIRST BE RE. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. MISCHIEF CONSULTANT.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
STERN STERN ALL RIGHT JONES
JONES NO ALAN HI ALAN BY EGGMAN
EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROWTH GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG HUESO AYE HUESO
ARI LAYERED HI LAYERED I LIVE
ALONE. LIMóN HI OKAY THAT IS
THE VOTES BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATED- MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANTS- WE. MISTER
ALLEN'S GONNA PRESENT A FILE
ITEM TWO IS THAT CORRECT. ARE
YOU UP FOR THAT MISTER ALLEN WE
HAVE HE SLOTTED YES TO A PRISON
AB SEVENTY. REGARDING THE
DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL WATERSHED IN
SANTA CATALINA ISLAND. YES. HE
DON'T YOU SOME TENTATIVE NO NO
I MEAN THIS IS THIS A SLIMMER
AND HONESTLY JUST ASK ME TO GET
SENATE- THIS IS A BILL THAT
WOULD EXPAND THE TERRITORY THE
SAN GABRIEL AND LOWER LOS
ANGELES RIVERS. AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY TO INCLUDE THE
DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL WATERSHED IN
THE SOUTHWEST PORTION OF L. A.
COUNTY. CANNELLA AND ALSO
CATALINA ISLAND. NASA SAID THAT
SINCE ITS ESTABLISHMENT TWENTY
YEARS AGO THE RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY A
SUCCESSFULLY PURSUED A MISSION
OF PRESERVING OPEN SPACE AND
HABITAT WHILE FACILITATING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S
WILDERNESS AND WILDLIFE. BY
PROVIDING GRANTS TO VARIOUS
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT ITS
TERRITORY IN EASTERN IOWA AND
WESTERN ORANGE COUNTY THE
CONSERVANCY IS IMPROVE
WATERSHEDS RESTORED WILDLIFE
HABITAT AND PROVIDED NUMEROUS
OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FOLKS FROM ALL OVER THE L. A.
REGION- WHILE THE CONSERVANCY
HAS HAD GREAT SUCCESS WITH
NUMEROUS PROJECTS WITHIN ITS
TERRITORY SEVERAL NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES AND NOT HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES. HOW THE
DIMMING IS CHANNEL WATERSHED
LOCATED TO THE WEST OF THE L.
A. RIVER IS ONE. AREA WITH
SEVERAL COMMUNITIES IN NEED.
AND INCLUDES CAR ST STE-
PORTIONS OF COMPTON GARDENA
HAWTHORNE LONG BEACH- YOU KNOW
INGLEWOOD AT SUCH A- ALSO
INCLUDING PORTIONS OF INGLEWOOD
AND YOU KNOW THAT SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES- THIS IS AN AREA
THAT'S THAT'S HEAVILY DEVELOPED
IT'S ALSO SEVERELY AXES THAT
LACKING IN PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
OPEN SPACE. IN ANOTHER AREA OF
NEED VERY DIFFERENT KIND OF
PLACES CATALINA ISLAND
CERTAINLY NOT NEED MORE OPEN
SPACE BY THE ACCESS TO THAT
OPEN SPACE CAN CERTAINLY PROVE
PROVE- SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE
AND THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF FUN A
RESOURCE CHALLENGES. NOW IT
SAID THE ISLAND'S DEPENDENCE ON
THE TOURISM INDUSTRY IS REALLY
LEFT IT UNABLE TO FIND LONG
TERM OPEN SPACE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN THE
WAKE OF THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. SO THIS CONSERVANCY
IS IN THE NEW PLACE UNIQUE
POSITION TO HELP THESE AREAS
ACTIVE SPEND THEIR MISSION. OF
PRESERVING. OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
ALL ENJOY AND THIS BILL WOULD-
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO DO
EXACTLY THAT BY EXPANDING THEIR
TERRITORY TO COVER THESE AREAS
AND SO. I KNOW I HAD TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS. SALLY ANN GARCIA
FROM THE RIVERS AMOUNTS
CONSERVANCY. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT- I SEE THAT WE HAVE LET'S
SEE. TO LEAD TO WITNESSES- YOU
MAY NOT HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT I DON'T SEE ANY. I'M
SORRY YES MISS GARCIA WITH SAN
GABRIEL. MR GARCIA A SINK APRIL
LOWER L. A. RIVER IS MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY I BELIEVE ON THE
LINE WITH LEAD SUPPORT. YEAH
HELLO GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
MS GARCIA PLEASE PROCEED.
THAT'S GREAT THANK THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF HONOR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE THANK YOU EVER LOWER LA
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS ARE BUSY
AND MENTION MY NAME IS SELLING
GARCIA MANAGER WITH A
CONSERVANCY OUR TERRITORY OF
CURLY OUTLINED BY LASTING OVER
A MOUNTAIN THE WATERSHED OF THE
SITE EVERY WHATEVER FROM ITS
HEADWATERS TO THE OUTLET INTO
THE PACIFIC OCEAN AND ORANGE
COUNTY. AND THE LOWER HALF OF
THE L. A. RIVER STARTING AND
THE CITY OF RUNNING TO THE PORT
OF LONG BEACH OUR PREPARATORY
FIRES OF JUST OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED SQUARE MILE EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHT WHAT AT A PRACTICE TWO
HUNDRED SEVEN SQUARE MILES WHAT.
40% OF THE CONSERVATIVE CURRENT
TERRITORY. BOTH HAVE A I'LL IS
THE BEING OF CHANNEL OF SAID
SHARE. OF THE CAR. OF THE LATE.
COMMUNITIES ANY. THAT EXISTS
WITHIN A CONSERVATIVE CURRENT.
THE AREA BUT THE NAY. IS
HEAVILY URBANIZED BY RELATIVELY
COMPLICATED DEVELOPMENT. THE
RESIDENTS ARE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY THE LACK OF A
LITTLE DEVELOPMENT OF GREEN AND
OPEN SPACES. DIFFICULT PART
PARTY BELIEVES DESERVE ACTION
IS NO DIFFERENT THAN A
COMMUNITY WITH THE CONSERVANCY
CURLY COMPRISES RESOURCES.
INCLUDING FUNDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THE EXPANSION WOULD
INCLUDE OF ANGLE AN AREA THAT
HAVE AN AVERAGE OF POINT EIGHT
ACRES OF PARKS PAVE PER ONE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS. AND AREA-
THIRTY NINE APARTMENT 39% OF
THE POPULATION LIVE BELOW TWO
TIMES THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
AND ONE POINT FIVE ACRES ONE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS INDICATE
WITH CITIES WITH LESS THAN
POINT FOUR ACRES. NO ONE OFF
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUPPORT
ELEMENTS OF THE CITY OF AVALON
GENERAL PLAN. WHICH INCLUDES
ACTION INCREASE PUBLIC
RECREATION AS WELL AS IMPROVING
ACCESS TO DOCUMENT OPEN SPACE
AREA AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
OVERALL HEALTH OF THE WATERSHED
AREA. HAT AB FOR ME LEAVE THEM
FIFTEEN OTHER CITIES COMMITTEE
UNINCORPORATED AREA. WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES ACT OF MILLIONS
OF BONTA ON IT PROGRAM DOLLARS
BUT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN PRIVY
TO. DOLLARS ARE MEANT TO BE
INDUCTED INTO THE CONVENIENCE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS TO ENJOY
OPEN SPACE. DEVOTED PUBLIC
ACCIDENT PREVENT AND HABITAT
CONSERVATION PROJECT. SUPPORT
YOUTH TRAINING PROGRAMS. AND
PROJECTS ARE IN LINE WITH
EXECUTIVE ORDERS. NINE EIGHTY
TO EIGHTY AND SO ON. THE BILL
WHAT THE SUPPORT INCLUDE PART
OF THE- AND GO PRIVILEGE.
BUDGET PROP SIXTY EIGHT. THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
CONSERVANCY TO MAXIMIZE THE-
GRAPH TO MULTI RECIPIENTS WELL
THE WATERSHED THEM L. A. RIVER.
DURING YOUR WEBER BUT THE MAKE
UP CHANNEL OF COURSE KIND OF
AND I. BAKER OPPORTUNITIES FOR
NEW AND EXPANDED ACCESS BUT
MAKING STATE FUNDING AVAILABLE
TO ELIGIBLE PROJECTS. PRODUCT
WITH BIRD JOB ECONOMIC GROWTH
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS OF
CONSERVATION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. THAT'S GOOD BILL
ISN'T JUST ABOUT MAKING THE
CONSERVATIVE TERRITORY BIGGER
ANY PUTTING STATE INVESTMENT
BACK INTO THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY. ESPECIALLY SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU SOME
ADVOCATES SAID- WE SHOULD
PROTECT YOU SO MUCH- MISTER SEA
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHERS ON THE LINE.
FOR GENERAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
LEAD WITNESSES SO. OPERATOR YOU
WANT TO OPEN THE LINE FOR I
DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM HERE TO TESTIFY IN PERSON
SO. NAME AFFILIATION SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
KNOWN AS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. OKAY VERY GOOD WE WILL
THEN TURN TO OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
OR TO REMOTE HEARING ROOMS. I
DO WANNA CHECK THE LINES
MODERATOR JUST TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES WE HAVE NONE LISTED
IN COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN MR
SURE NO ONE IS QUEUING UP. OKAY
I WILL BRING BACK TO DIE CENTER
EARLIER YEAH I HAD A QUESTION
OR TWO AND IT MIGHT BE GOOD FOR
THE WITNESS RATHER THAN. THEN
PUT MISTER ALLEN ON SPOT OKAY
IT IS THE RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY PERSON STILL ON THE
PHONE. IT'S GARCIA YOU STILL
WITH US. THERE ARE TWO
QUESTIONS THE FIRST ONE IS.
THERE'S A PLANNING PROCESS IT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR QUITE A WHILE
FOR THE LOS ANGELES RIVER IN
THE LOWER RIVER IS UNDER THE
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY WITH THE AREAS THAT
ARE CONTAINED IN THIS ADDITION.
B. HAVE THEY ALREADY BEEN
INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS OR
WOULD THEY BE THIS BRING THEM
INTO THE L. A. RIVER PROCESS
FOR THE FIRST TIME. OKAY
ACTUALLY WE- AFTER ALLEN HAD
STATED WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS ARE OVER
TWENTY YEARS- SO IT'S TIME TO
UPDATE OUR OPEN SPACE PLAN WE
ARE CURRENTLY UPDATING OUR OPEN
SPACE PLAN ALSO KNOWN OF COMMON
GROUND WITH INCOMES FROM OTHER
CONSERVANCY DUE TO THE MULTI
AGENCY EFFORT TO UPDATE WILL
INCLUDE METROPOLITAN AREA DARK
CURLY NOT PART OF OUR TERRITORY
WHAT'S IN. THE UPDATE WILL
REVIEW FUNDING ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC NEEDS OF THE AREA
WHICH INCLUDES THE EXPANSION
THE EXPANDED AREA OF DIMMING OF
CHANNEL AND CATALINA ISLAND. I
THINK THAT WAS A YES BUT I'M
NOT ENTIRELY SURE. IT YEAH BIG
BIG BECAUSE- THE ISSUE IS
THERE'S AN ELABORATE PLANNING
PROCESS AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HISTORY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO SENATOR STERN'S DISTRICT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY
THE LOWER PART OF THE RIVER WAS
INVOLVED AND GOT OUT AHEAD OF
THE PLANNING AND SO. I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF. IF THE
AREAS ADDED WERE INVOLVED AND I
THINK YOU'RE SAYING THEY'RE
GOING TO BE INVOLVED IF THEY
WEREN'T INVOLVED ALREADY. THE
COULD SECOND QUESTION I HAD IS
I HAVE A VAGUE RECOLLECTION
THAT THERE WAS A PRIVATE
CONSERVANCY THAT EXISTED FOR
THE CAMERA WE CATALINA ISLAND
OR OUT THERE. IS THIS
COORDINATING WITH THAT PRIVATE
CONSERVANCY IS IT SUBSUMING IT
IS THERE SOME RESOURCES THEY
BRING TO THE TABLE IT MIGHT
COME TO RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS IF
THIS. IF THIS BILL PASSES. VERY
GOOD QUESTION WE HAVE ACTUALLY
MET WITH THE CITY AVALON AS
WELL THE CATALINA CONSERVANCY.
THE CATALINA CONSERVANCY IS A
NONPROFIT THAT IS NOT A STATE
AGENCY. SO WHAT THIS EFFORT
WITH OF EXPANSION WE'D BE ABLE
TO. ASSIST EACH OTHER- ON
EITHER EXPANDING OR
REVITALIZING THEIR HABITAT ON
THAT ISLAND. AND THEN WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST TO THE AUTHOR- IS
DEAD HE ACTUALLY BE EXPLICIT
ABOUT WHAT COORDINATION IS
GOING TO BE SO THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T PASS AND THE NEXT THING
WE KNOW THERE'S SOME
NEGOTIATION GOING ON THAT COULD
HAVE HAPPENED AT THE TIME WE
WERE DOING THE BILL SO I WOULD
JUST SUGGEST THAT THE AUTHORS.
HAVE THOSE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS AND CLARIFY THAT
BEFORE THE BILL'S DONE A WITH
THAT. A MISTER CHAIR OUT
THERE'S A COUPLE OF SUGGESTIONS
THERE BROKE WITH THAT I'LL BE
READY TO MOVE THE BILL WHENEVER
BUT DISCUSSION IS. DONE GREAT.
GREAT THANK YOU- AND JUST TO
CLARIFY- THE DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL
IS NOT A PART OF THE L. A.
RIVER IT'S WEST OF THE RIVER
THERE IS A TRIBUTE TO THERE IS
A- PROBLEM LET ME TELL YOU. MAY
TELL YOU THAT FIRST BILL THAT
THAT PASSED DIDN'T INCLUDE
TRIBUTARIES AND THEN I HAD A
NUMBER OF SENATORS SOME OF
WHICH I AM SERVING WITH NOW.
LAND ON ME TO MAKE SURE THAT
TRIBUTARIES WERE ADDED TO THE
BILL AND SO EVEN THOUGH IT
MIGHT JUST BE A TRIBUTARY IT'S
LIKE I'M TRYING TO PRESUPPOSE
THE CONFLICT BEFORE. IT LANDS
ON SOME BUT YET I'M JUST NOT
SURE IT'S A TRIBUTARY I WOULD
LOVE TO GET WELL WE'LL LET
WE'LL LET THEM CLARIFY THAT
OVERTIME. I THINK I'VE RAISED
THAT ISSUE WITH THE OTHER ISSUE
IN THE AUTHOR CAN. FIGURE OUT
IF THOSE ISSUES AND DEAL WITH I
KNOW THAT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE IMPACTED ARE CERTAINLY.
INVOLVED WITH THE BILL
SUPPORTING THE BILL WORKING
WITH THE CONSERVANCY IN THE
AUTHOR BUT AND- I DON'T KNOW
THAT I KNOW. AREN'T I KNOW
SUPPORT THE BILL YEAH IT'S HOW
DIFFERENT RAISES AN ISSUE
THAT'S ON THE DRESS THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED THAT'S ALL YEP.
YEP GOOD POINT. ALL RIGHT SO WE
WILL KEEP AN EYE ON THAT ISSUE
GOING FORWARD AND- IT SHOULD
THE AUTHOR WANT TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS. ANY L.
A. RIVER PLANNING- COMMITTEE
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT THAT- BUT
FOR NOW WE HAVE THIS BILL
BEFORE US HERE TODAY. WHICH AT
SANTA CATALINA ISLAND AND THE
DIMMING IS CHANNEL WATERSHED
TO- THIS CONSERVANCY THERE'S A
MOTION FROM CENTER LATER DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MISTER.
PROXY AUTHOR WOULD YOU. PLEASE
CLOSE HERE RECEIVE THE
DISCUSSION- THAT WILL
CERTAINLY. HELP TO FACILITATE-
FIVE GIVEN THE ANSWERS THAT
THAT- CENTER LAYERED CORRECTLY
RAISES AND RESPECT S. RIGHT
ABOUT. VERY GOOD- SO THE MOST
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI
BERMAN HI JONES. JONES IRA
ALLEN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
HI EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROOVE.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG ARGUED WAY
SO WE SO I LAYERED HI THERE ARE
YOU ALONE. LIMóN ALL RIGHT.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY THAT'S EIGHT
ZERO- DO WE NEED TO LEAVE THE
MEASURE ON CALL- YES ONE ABSENT
MEMBER OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THE
MEASURE ON CALL- LET'S GO BACK
THE THROUGH THE REST OF FILE
HERE NOW THAT WE HAVE. SOME OF
THE ABSENT MEMBERS- WANTED
FIRST JUST OPEN UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LET'S START THERE. ON
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
LIMóN. LIMóN HI THAT'S NINE
ZERO OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON THE
FILE ITEM THREE THAT'S AB TWO
TO THREE. FILE ITEM THREE AB
TWO TO THREE CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO GROVE. WUERZBURG
WUERZBURG R. A. LONG LIMóN HI.
GROUP ALL RIGHT. IT IS NINE
ZERO OKAY THAT MEASURES OUT
CLOSE ROLE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
RIVAS GLORIA DO FOR START UP
THIS GOOD FOR YOU I APOLOGIZE
FILE ITEM FOR AB FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE OPEN UP. SB FIVE HUNDRED
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
LIMóN. THAT IS. SIX TWO OKAY
THAT MEASURE SIX TO THE
MEASURES APT- CLOSE THE ROLE OF
FILING A NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE REAVIS. EVEN A
QUESTION STERN YES I THINK- I
KNOW SHE MENTIONED IT BUT I
WANT TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
THAT MEASURE THAT WAS DISCUSSED.
IT WAS AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE YEAH
IF IT WASN'T ALL TALK TO OUR
OFFICE- IT WAS NOT BUT WE CAN
WE CAN WORK YOU IN. I THINK WE
HAVE A- WE ARE AMENDING THE
BILL. THANK YOU OKAY. SO THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIVE. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE RIVAS FIVE EIGHT
FIVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO ALLEN. HI ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HUESO. HUESO OUR IN
THE MOMENT. LOON I'D NINE ZERO
OKAY THAT MEASURES OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SIX FORTY
TWO FRIEDMAN SB SIX FORTY TO
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO
JONES. JONES HI HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HUESO HUESO
ALL RIGHT THAT IS NINE ZERO
OKAY THAT MEASURES OUT MOVING
N FILE ITEM TWELVE MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR GABRIEL.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOR THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TWO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
SEVEN TWO. OKAY SEVENTY TWO-
THAT MEASURES OUT CLOSE THE
ROLE OFONE FINAL ITEM DO WE
HAVE TO RE OPEN CONSENT WAS
THAT IT WE HAVE. FILE ITEM. TWO
FILE ITEM TO. FILE ITEM AB
EIGHT OPEN THE- THAT SAY OKAY
SO WE'LL CLOSE ON FILE ITEM TO.
AND THAT DOES IT. IT SAYS TO
RESEARCH THE WATER HEREBY
ADJOURNED.